mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché car en faisant mes analyses
de séquences j'ai massacré toute votre
enfance
bon j'ai pas envie de faire cette vidéo
j'ai pas du tout envie de faire cette
vidéo ce qui fait qu'elle qualifie très
bien pour un des bonnes kg pénitence il
faut que je paye faut que je paye pour
mes péchés et aujourd'hui on va parler
de cette vidéo qui s'intitule non on ne
vient pas tous d'afrique
déjà rien que le titre donc le titre ça
va pas non ne vient pas tous d'afrique
encore la vidéo s'appellerait non on ne
vient pas d'afrique
elle ne ferait partie que de ces
millionième vidéo qui dit que non on
vient d'europe en fait on vient pas
d'afrique
il y en a plein même arte a fait un
reportage là dessus donc ben voilà mais
là elle s'appelle non on ne vient pas
tous d'afrique et là ça fait appel mais
à tout ce qu'il ya de plus laid dans la
paléoanthropologie on ne va pas tous
d'afrique
ça fait appel au modèle multi régional
chaque espèce d'êtres humains sur la
planète
enfin chaque race alors c'est parti on
va utiliser maurras considéré qu'à
chaque fois que jean mauras il ya des
guillemets dessus voilà donc chaque race
humaine vient d'une espèce différente le
erectus a donné l'homme asiatique
néandertal a donné l'homme européen
ergaster a donné l'homme africain c'est
laid comme théorie seles a été
abandonnée depuis des années depuis
qu'on a fait les analyses génétiques
voilà depuis qu'on a fait des analyses
génétiques d'homo sapiens on sait que
toutes les espèces enfin on sait que
toutes les races d'homo sapiens viennent
d'afrique
on le sait parce que d'une toute la joue
toute la diversité 80 % au-delà de la
diversité génétique humaine est en
afrique est de 2 bat parce que
phylogénétiquement le tous les êtres
humains viennent d'un ancêtre en commun
et que cet ancêtre en com a vu que toute
la diversité génétique et en afrique
bâle via d'afrique quoi donc cette
analyse génétique elles ont prouvé qu'il
n'y avait pas de l'homo erectus et tout
ça ils n'avaient pas ils n'avaient rien
à voir là dedans
les analyses génétiques ont grâce à
l'horloge moléculaire on sait que cet
ancêtre avait alors les datations elles
sont un peu large mais en gros c'est
entre 120 mille et trois cent mille ans
c'est un peu large mais ça va quand même
pas cherché jusqu'à homo erectus a donc
trois cent mille ans et à la limite
c'est dahlberg n 6 en afrique
donc c'est déjà plus homo erectus ni
homo ergaster ni homo côte ce soit ces
aides et de bergues m6 c'est déjà un
prix humain sait déjà c'est déjà un ce
qu'on pourrait appeler anne homo sapiens
archaïque donc dans certaines régions il
est appelé homo sapiens archaïque c'est
un peu plus compliqué que ça mais bref
j'ai fait toute une vidéo là dessus donc
je vais pas revenir sur l'évolution
humaine tout entière
j'ai fait des cures de paléo mammalogie
qui sont juste là et voilà cette vidéo
là les hominidés évolution humaine tout
est résumé donc tous le goût tout ce que
je peux vous dire sur l'évolution
humaine est là dedans non bref le titre
pose problème déjà nom vient pas tous
d'afrique ça veut dire modèle multi
régional et il n'y a plus qu'un seul
scientifique pour soutenir cette théorie
et ses ouailles pof et wolf
il fait consensus avec personne voilà
donc et puis du coup faut qu'il ferme
les yeux sur la génétique complètement
parce que s'il ya le seul moyen de ne
pas croire de croire en la théorie
multirégional c'est de fermer totalement
les yeux sur la paléogène sur la
génétique et maintenant la
paléogénétique puisqu'on commence aussi
à avoir des données
des données génétiques qui montre que
même même les
certes un certain heldenbergh m6 tombe à
l'extérieur d'homo sapiens et homo
erectus tombe aussi à l'extérieur d'homo
sapiens pareil on en avait parlé dans
une autre vidéo qui était qui était qui
était un paléo news
attendez que je le retrouve niveau
montage je vais faire aucun effort
je vous assure tous les tous les petits
morceaux de trucs où je vais chercher
les preuves et tout ça vous allez
voulait taper un nom j'ai vraiment pas
envie de la faire à cette vidéo je vous
assure donc tous ces petits morceaux de
douleur là que vous êtes en train de
subir en ce moment parce que je faut que
je cherche les moments où je parlais de
telle ou telle chose voilà c'est ce truc
là
donc voilà c'est un article qui a été
publié très récemment et vous voyez ici
néandertal denisova machin et vous voyez
ici homo erectus complètement à
l'extérieur donc il n'ya pas de où se
trouve homo sapiens sur cette phylogénie
d'ailleurs est ce qu'ils ont vraiment
oublié de mettre homo sapiens sur la
phylogénie bref donc de mes bons d
analyse paléogénétique on en a et voilà
donc il n'ya pas de ya pas de doute sur
le fait que homo sapiens a une origine
africaine
point barre voilà donc et pas si les
dons bref donc ça se sent ça sent la le
racisme voilà c'est juste ça voilà ça
sent le racisme le modèle multi régional
était basé sur après qu'une pré
conception raciste que l'homme européen
ne pouvait pas avoir dans cette
rencontre
évidemment avec l'âme africain
évidemment qu'il descendait de
néandertal localement ce qui est con
parce que néandertal descend aussi d'un
haut d'un homme africain mais bref
donc bref voilà déjà le titre m'énerve
la règle enfin les multiples règles de
des bonnes kg pénitence sont d'une faut
pas que ça me plaise il faut vraiment
pas que j'ai envie de le faire 2 2
il faut que la personne est plus
d'abonnés ce qui est le cas 33 mille
abonnés à l'heure où on parle je n'ai
que je n'ai que je n'ai que dix même pas
encore dix-huit mille abonnés donc il en
a presque deux fois plus que moi
et la vidéo à 15000 vu la dernière fois
qu'on a fait une vidéo à 15000 vue voilà
ça devait être un accident donc donc on
risque pas de lui faire deux trois
c'était le nombre de vue la vidéo à
15000 huron va pas lui faire de pub mais
en même temps comme il n'a pas beaucoup
plus d'abonnés que nous on pourra pas
non plus m'accuser de vouloir
m'accrocher à sa popularité voilà on
n'est pas sur des 200 milles abonnés ou
quatre cent mille abonnés donc c'est pas
là m'a fâché non plus donc voilà on
m'accusera pas non plus de vouloir me
remorqué à lui niveau popularité
d'ailleurs je m'en fous un peu de sa
popularité a tout pour être tout à fait
honnête alors ça vient d'une chaîne qui
s'appelle pagannes tv la description la
description aussi elle fait peur la
théorie out of africa était balayée par
les dernières découvertes relayés sur
arte c'est désormais out our pas arte ta
source c'est arte lemay qui prétend
contredire le mec il prétend contredire
sentant s'entendent paléoanthropologie
depuis la découverte du premier
australopithèques en 1924
on sait que l'origine humaine est en
afrique est le mec prétend contredire ça
avec arte comme source
artix source d'ailleurs que j'ai
d'ailleurs c'est le reportage que
j'avais déjà des bunkers en long en
large et en travers
parce que oui je suis un chien de garde
de la théorie d'afrique
voilà de l'homme originaire d'afrique
donc vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
m'insulter en commentaire je suis je
suis un énorme chien de garde de la
théorie de de l'homme né en afrique et
j'avais déjà défoncée ce reportage ici
voilà dans cette vidéo là alors je vais
pas dire point par point parce qu'au
final le reportage se contredit
tellement lui même qu'au final il n'y a
pas vraiment besoin que j'y passe trois
quarts d'heure voyait le fait qu'une
demi heure la vidéo c'est un exemple
classique de cherry picking donc devront
choisir les preuves qu'on veut et là-bas
typiquement ils ont compris que les
preuves qui viennent d'europe en
négligeant mais totalement tout ce qui
se passe en afrique à la même époque
donc bref
et puis ça va être le cas dans cette
vidéo là je suis sûr parce que c'est le
seul moyen encore une fois de contredire
la théorie de l'homme originaire
d'afrique c'est qu'il faut ignorer les
milliers de fossiles qu'on a découvert
en afrique parce qu'il y en a
littéralement des milliers au monal et
dit tout seul il ya 15000 fossiles et
encore je compte que les fossiles qui
ont été trouvés dans la chambre
d'inhaler dit maintenant il ya une
nouvelle chambre qui s'appelle la
chambre de laisser 10 donc de la grotte
où on trouve au monal et dis donc à une
nouvelle chambre avec deux nouveaux
fossiles donc je compte il ya 15000
ossements d'aumône allez dis que dans la
chambre d'inhaler dis donc
et ça c'est que homo naledi donc sachant
qu'on a encore homo ergaster homo
erectus et dahlberg n 6 pour ne compter
que les plus connus est évidemment homo
sapiens archaïque donc et
australopithèques us et et toumaï donc
ça elle entre aux puces et or or in et
j'en oubliais ardipithecus voilà donc
autant dire que tu en auras pour un
moment a des bonnes qui tous les
fossiles à parent je veux dire avant de
commencer à penser à une origine en
europe faut commencer par des jeunes qui
tous les fossiles à parent qu'on a
découvert en afrique
bon courage comme j'ai dit en a des
milliers on doit être tu peux écrire un
bouquin si tu veux tu peux écrire un
bouquin mais bref donc il se base sur ce
reportage d'arte est évidemment parce
qu'il ya qu un seul reportage sur arte
où il est où il essayait de défoncer la
théorie de l'homme originaire d'europe
c'est celui là l'europe le berceau de
l'humanité pour l'interrogation la
réponse est
on voit là et si vous voulez en savoir
plus vous pouvez aller voir cette vidéo
là dans cette vidéo l'a d'ailleurs où je
passe déjà un bon moment à damon qu'est
le bouzin il ya des liens en plus en
dessous parce que évidemment c'est pas
le seul contenu que j'ai fait en
référence à l'origine soit disant
européenne
il y avait jamais fait j'avais donné une
interview pour scepticisme scientifique
à l'époque de la sortie de la première
preuve entre guillemets et puis la
deuxième preuve j'avais fait un paléo
news
et puis la troisième et puis après il ya
la vidéo ea puis après il ya ma vidéo
sur le l'évolution humaine
et puis il yal agence science-presse n'y
a pas que moi évidemment qui critiquent
sa tout le monde critique ça évidemment
pas ce que c'est si ouvertement
critiquable je veux dire le problème le
problème c'est pas je disais tout à
l'heure je suis un chien de garde mais
je suis pas un chien de garde le
problème c'est que les preuves sont
mauvaises c'est tout je veux dire pas
d'autres y a pas d'autre façon de le
dire et elle était mauvaise depuis le
départ donc cette théorie là comme quoi
le soi-disant le l'être humain serait
origines d'afrique
elle vient de sa grille copie t cus ces
fossiles là que je vous montre gris
copie take us c'est quoi ces sept
mandibules dégueulasse un sas et une
mâchoire inférieure vous voyez les dents
elles sont défoncés donc autant dire que
vous faites rien avec en mammalogie si
on n'a pas les dents on fait rien du
tout et vous avez 7 ratiches isolé cette
dent a été découvert en grèce et cette
prémolaires elle a été découverte en
bulgarie donc déjà rien que vouloir dire
que cette dans la appartient au même
animal que cette mâchoire là on est à la
limite de la science fiction
1 et alors après vouloir changer
totalement le scénario évolutif humains
pour cette ce morceau de merde la maman
non et donc j'avais écrit à l'époque
évidemment on avait été contacté parce
que vu que je travaille en afrique en
afrique du sud
les journalistes avaient appelé panic
est en nous demandant mais est ce que
c'est vrai et puis j'ai été le seul bien
daigné répondre
et non c'est pas vrai
je leur ai expliqué que bah oui bah vous
avez une banque est complètement isolée
de la main la mâchoire donc déjà dire
que ça va partir à la même espèce ça
marche pas ou moyennement
et puis après base et une quelconque
base et un tel changement de paradigme
sur sur ça voilà ça vaut pas grand chose
quoi et puis surtout et donc c'est ce
que j'explique dans cet article la voilà
il n'y a pas assez de preuves pour
soutenir le l'hypothèse le claim sais
pas comment traduire ça l'hypothèse que
les humains sont originaires d'europe
donc dans cet article qui est juste un
article journalistique un jeu le dire
mais c'est moi qui l'ait écrit en
collaboration avec les journalistes donc
au moins je sais ce qu'il ya dedans et
je sais que ce qu'il ya dedans est bon
et dancette c'est ce que j'explique dans
cet article quoi du coup c'est juste
c'est juste un très mauvais fossiles et
puis voilà on peut lui faire dire un peu
ce qu'on veut quoi alors ouais il est
athée de sept millions d'années si je me
rappelle bien ouais 7,2 même si on veut
et alors et alors ça reste un mauvais
fossiles et puis surtout il ya un gros
problème dans la dans l'article qui
parle qui décrit ce bout de mâchoire il
ya un énorme problème
je vais essayer de vous le trouvez c'est
cet article la voilà donc c'est un
article paru dans plos one
donc c'est quand même un article paru
dans une revue à comité de lecture ça
reste du sérieux c'est pas non plus
c'est pas non plus de la pseudo science
met donc dans cette description le
problème c'est que vous pourrez chercher
partout il n'y a aucune analyse
phylogénétique c'est à dire que le
moment où on démontre scientifiquement
que gréco pittacus et potentiellement au
moins le groupe frères sinon lance être
enfin lancé être sinon - le groupe frère
de des zones mini donc des delà de la
lignée humaine
ben y'en a pas voilà voyez là vous
pouvez chercher il n'y a pas d'arbres
phylogénétique là dedans je repasse
encore un petit coup juste pour gagner
du temps
non pour que la vidéo soit plus longue
donc je repasse encore un petit coup
voyez pas d' analyse phylogénétique rien
bla bla up générique de fin ça c'est le
générique de fin quand on met les
publications qu'on a cité et pouf
voilà le fond de l'article il est là
donc c'est ça grieco pitt et cus c'est
c'est une cdc du mauvais fossiles qui a
été analysé en profondeur
bon ça c'est bien faire je le dire mais
bon bah du coup avec un mauvais fossiles
même en même en trouvant un mauvais
fossiles même s'il est du même âge que
sahelanthropus grosso modo parce que ça
elle entre aux puces c'est pareil il est
environ 7 7,2 7,3 millions d'années ben
même en étant du même âge que ça il
entre aux puces ça prouve rien quoi
sahel entre eux plus c'est quand même un
crâne entier quoi c'est quand même autre
chose ça elle entre au plus il ya des
caractères définitivement hominiens
dessus donc ça elle entre aux puces et
toumaï et toumaï il a quand même sur le
crâne on voit quand même la canine qui
est réduite et qu'il ya une usure
apicale qui suggère que les danses en
boîte est comme chez les humains
c'est-à-dire les canines devant l'eca
ligne du dessus devant les canines du
dessous alors que si vous regardez un
gorille c'est les canines du dessous qui
sont au devant les canines du dessus
donc chez un humain vous avez ça là je
vais essayer de faire un agrandissement
pour vous voyez donc chez les humains
pardon chez les humains vous avez ça les
canines du dessus sans boîte devant les
canines du dessous et chez un gorille et
un chimpanzé vous avez ça donc les
canines du dessous qui viennent devant
les cabines du dessus et ça c'est ça
c'est une différence fondamentale entre
humains et chimpanzés et gorilles donc
et ça ça se voit surtout mal parce que
surtout my on voit l'usure de la canine
du dessus qui se faisait derrière enfin
plutôt sur le dessus et derrière la cani
sur la canine supérieur ça se voit chez
gréco pittacus bas vous le verrez jamais
parce que ya pas de cannes il n'y a rien
il ya les dents sont complètement bouffé
donc même si les dents même si les
canines sont relativement petit chez
gréco pittacus ce qui est aussi un
caractère de minya de minignan
le problème c'est que c'est aussi un
caractère qu'on retrouve chez d'autres
espèces de grands singes comme houran au
pit et cus et comme comme aurait opté
cus ça c'est définitivement out c'est
que c'est complètement à l'extérieur de
la lignée humaine et on le sait
donc voilà donc le caractère qu'ils
essayent de mettre en avant pour dire
que c'est un nominé c'est le fait que
les racines de la 4è prémolaires
inférieurs sont à moitié fusionner et je
crois que c'est ça qu'on nous montre ici
donc la quatrième prémolaires inférieur
et les racines sont à moitié fusionner
ce qui est un état intermédiaire c'est
ce qu'ils disent ici ce qui est un état
intermédiaire entre la condition humaine
qu'on trouve chez elle entre aux puces
par exemple est la condition primates où
les racines sont complètement séparés
donc la condition humaine les racines
sont complètement fusionné la condition
primates
c'est les racines qui sont séparés et
est le problème le problème c'est que
comme ils disent ici bas c'est quand
même un caractère qu'on retrouve chez
les grands singes
il y en a que 2 à 4 % qu'ils n'ont chez
les grands singes moderne mais enfin du
coup ça n'exclut pas totalement la
possibilité que le greco pittacus fasse
partie de ces 2 à 4%
alors je sais que dans un contexte de
l'interprétation du registre fossile il
vaut mieux admettre que notre fausse il
fait partie de la moyenne que de partie
des exceptions mais bon sachant que déjà
le matos de base et pas très très bon
sachant que tu as que ce caractère qui
soutient la position de ce truc là parmi
les homininés enfin qu'il soutiendrait
ce quart à segré copie tqs comme un
nominé basse et maigrichon quoi ces
maigres et du coup ça casse un peu tout
ça casse un peu tout donc bah voilà
grieco pittacus ne suffit pas à
démontrer l'origine humaine
enfin le l'origine humaine en europe
et d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs on avait
écrit un article avec mes collègues sud
africain là dessus donc on avait fait
justement une analyse cladistique de
greco pittacus afin d'obtenir un arbre
phylogénétique arbres phylogénétiques
qui ne donne pas donc en l'absence
d'arbres phylogénétique larry potez
aller caduque
et puis bah sans surprise gréco pittacus
à l'extérieur quoi donc on l'arbre
phylogénétique voici gréco pitt est qu
stocks
voici les humains pan et goya et
kopitz cus tombe à l'extérieur alors des
fois ils tombent comme plus proches
parents des deux des humains de pan et
de gorilla mais bon c'est tout quoi je
tiens y'a pas y'a pas de quoi crier à la
révolution de l'origine humaine quoi ce
y aussi tant que temps que pan et
gorillaz c'est à dire les chimpanzés et
les gorilles sont les plus proches
parents des homininés banc et gorilla ce
sont des espèces africaines donc sa
place toujours l'origine de ceux de
cette divergence là en afrique
donc voilà tant que gréco pittacus ne
détrône pas le chimpanzé clairement ben
sa place toujours l'origine humaine en
afrique
donc voilà est évidemment évidemment ils
ont répondu à cet article évidemment
qu'ils ont répondu à cet article en
disant que notre analyse
elle était doublée du cul c'est vrai
qu'elle a des défauts je veux dire elle
est pas parfaite cette analyse notamment
parce que penser gorilla son groupe
frère alors que pan devrait être groupe
frère avec les au mini donc est là elle
a des défauts cette analyse mais enfin
bon le truc c'est cru ça fais gaffe à
l'art analyse eux-mêmes parce qu' ils
répondent ils nous répondent à nous en
nous disant votre analyse aller daubé du
cul c'est pas bien ouais et aller où
votre analyse pas d'eau hbe du cul pour
nous montrer que vous avez raison ok
vous montrer que nous éventuellement on
peut avoir tort j'accepte même si je
suis pas d'accord mais j'accepte mais
montrez nous que vous avez raison c'est
quand même ça le problème de base c'est
eux qui affirme c'est eux qui affirme
que l'origine et en europe et est pas en
afrique elles sont vos preuves vous avez
toujours pas de preuves
voilà donc oui l'analyste claude estime
qu'elle est peut-être pas parfaite mais
au moins elle existe et elle montre que
gréco pittacus out
voilà et c'est tout
e donc voilà tout ça ces partis grecs
copies tqc puis après il ya eu un
enchaînement avec des empreintes en
grèce et tout ça c'est des cris dans le
reportage art et j'en parle aussi dans
mon des bonnes cage alors je vais aller
vite fait d empreinte en grèce d'un
primate bipèdes monde et empreintes qui
sont pas très joli pour être tout à fait
honnête
enfin bref voilà soit ça c'est censé
être un pouce ça c'est censé être un
talon ça c'est censé être des doigts on
n'en voit que quatre
c'est bon là on envoie cinq emplissant
bien les yeux ici bon admettons que ce
soit des empreintes
c'est pas très joli déjà et puis surtout
elle date de 5,7 millions d'années donc
5,7 millions d'années on a déjà tout
maya 7 millions d'années bien avant donc
pareil ça prouve pas une origine
à la limite ça prouve sa pourrai prouver
que des humains ont traversé la
méditerranée bien avant combien avant la
sortie d'afrique d'homo erectus il ya
1,8 million d'années voire deux millions
d'années
mais voilà ça prouverait d
éventuellement des trucs genre
ardipithecus moreau wrinn ont pu se
balader en europe
bon des empreintes c'est léger surtout
surtout que encore une fois il ya
possiblement des primates bipèdes qui
existait en europe peut-être pas il ya
cinq 5 5 millions et demi d'années
la plupart je crois avait disparu mais
on a des primates européens comme
oreiller au pit et cus qui était bipède
il était bipède arboricole mais bon ça
veut dire que de manière générale leur
posture était plutôt bip est donc il
était possiblement capable de se balader
de façon bipèdes au sol bon après c'est
pareil ça a été contesté aussi le aurait
opté q ce bipède
c'est aussi ça a été contesté récemment
avec une analyse des vertèbres lombaires
si je me rappelle mais bon bref des
primates bipèdes il en existe il ya qu à
regarder les chimpanzés
occasionnellement il se balade de façon
bipèdes sur toutes ses empreintes en
parle en plus elles sont très petit
c'est pas impossible qu'elle ait été
faite à un juvénile si vous regardez
l'échelle par rapport
si vous regardez l'échelle l'échelle
l'échelle trouvons l'échelle mais voilà
c'est un tout petit pied un ce truc là
évidemment je vais passer trois plombes
à trouver une échelle donc là la barre
d'échelle est là et elle fait elle fait
5 cm donc voilà on est sur un pied qui
est pas
vous êtes sur un pied qui fait même pas
10 cm de long - donc c'est pas un gros
gros pied donc c'est possible que ce
soit un juge et neil de quelque chose
d'autre avec eux ce juvénile en question
se balader de façon bipèdes c'est pareil
à moi aussi je peux faire des hypothèses
ad-hoc pour pour dire que j'ai raison
mais voilà ça ne prouve pas en tout cas
de toute façon à 5,7 millions d'années
on pourra pas une origine humaine une
origine humaine en europe
et puis le dernier maillon de la chaîne
s'était danube used as new skies à ce
que l'être un peu plus complet gréco
pittacus mais qui est aussi un peu plus
récent si je me rappelle bien non il a
quel âge
ah non il a 11 millions d'années au
temps pour moi donc des news j'en avais
aussi parlé dans un palais aux news donc
pareil on avait possiblement sur un
primate bipèdes donc un grand singe
bipèdes d'ailleurs ça pourrait faire
écho à ses empreintes un grand singe
possiblement bipèdes
encore que il ya deux problèmes
fondamentaux encore une fois dans cette
analyse
vous pourrez la sq rôle et jusqu'en bas
du bout du monde vous ne trouverez
toujours pas d' analyse phylogénétique
qui montre que danubius étaient proches
parents des amis ni donc même problème
que grecque au pit et cus et
deuxièmement le mode de locomotion
qu'ils y dont ils font l'hypothèse pour
danubius sans rentrer dans les détails
c'est un mode de locomotion qui n'existe
plus chez les espèces modernes d'après
eux
donc c'est carrément monté stable pour
pas dire à peine scientifique
voilà donc ça pose problème encore une
fois ça pose encore énormément problème
mais voilà le plus gros problème reste
quand même qu' il n'y a pas d' analyse
phylogénétique qui montre que dany vieux
c'est plus proche des homininés que d'un
autre grand sage et et ce coup là je me
suis pas fendu d'une analyse parce que
j'en ai marre de j'en ai marre de me
répéter et une dernière preuve qui passe
souvent sous le radar parce que
j'apprends aux gens aussi à
à trouver des preuves pour leurs
théories et bullshit voilà il ya une
autre preuve qui est passé pas mal sous
le radar c'est la découverte d'une dent
en allemagne qui est pareil qui est
relativement vieille je ne sais plus
exactement la date on va regarder dans
l'abstract parce que ça doit être x ça
doit être écrit dans l'abstract voilà
9,7 millions d'années apparemment donc
pareil on est autour de 10 millions
d'années et danser dans ce truc qui
trouva nominee d une mais c'est juste
une dedans je crois il ya deux pauvres
dans une dent est une maladie une canine
et une molaire donc elles ont des
caractéristiques de alors elles ont des
caractéristiques domino id notamment la
présence d'une crête oblique
la crise n'a oublié qui est
définitivement un truc de grand singe
donc des hominoïdes l'émail et plissée
comme chez les hominoïdes donc ca
nominaux id d'il ya 10 millions d'années
mais sous de la dire que pareil vous
pourrez toujours cherché l'analyse
phylogénétique qui montre que ce truc là
est plus proches parents des humains que
de quoi que ce soit d'autre vous ne la
trouverez pas voilà un an des analyses
statistiques vous en aurez un mais bon
ça ça n'exclut pas la convergence
évolutive
c'est bien ça tout le problème donc
voilà ils ont encore envie de vous dire
que c'est de l'hominidé comme le montre
ce magnifique graphique tout en vous
mettant ici un pli au pit est qu ce qui
est honteux qui n'est même pas un grand
singe je veux dire priorités qu'il s'est
à peine sait même pas considéré comme un
grand singe comme un domino id quoi s'il
me rappelle bien vous voyez cardy pitt
est qu ses priorités qu s'il se
ressemble vachement là vous voyez cardy
pittacus vous en avez un au dessus et en
dessous donc ça veut dire que puyoô
pittacus il est aussi très très
similaire au niveau de sa canine
ardipithecus alors qu'on sait que là on
a du matos un peu plus conséquent pour
priorité qc on sait qu'il a rien à
[ __ ] chez les hominoïdes et encore
moins chez les e mini est donc là donc
la plupart des gens considèrent que
c'est dans l appareil n appartiennent à
un pays au pit et sid et donc voilà
bottage en touche
voilà c'est tout à chaque fois en fait
le tout la théorie là là où je veux en
venir en vous présentant tout ça c'est
que toute la théorie que les humains
viendrait d'europe elle est basée déjà
sur des fossiles bien isolé bien
fragmentaires
et sur des analyses qui sont pas
complètes c'est ne pas faire d' analyse
phylogénétique quand on veut démontrer
un truc comme ça c'est comme vouloir
démontrer que deux et deux font 5 sans
jamais faire le calcul
c'est un truc qui est évident pour tout
le monde
l'origine africaine de l'humanité comme
deux et deux font quatre et c est
vouloir démontrer que deux et deux font
5 donc l'homme vient d'europe
c'est faux moi refaire le calcul jeudi
mais évidemment si vous faites le calcul
vous trouvez que ça fait 4 évidemment
donc on fait pas le calcul ont fait pâle
analyse phylogénétique et basta on est
libéré des livres et je ne reviendrai
plus jamais donc voilà c'est du matos
parcellaire et c'est du matos qui n'a
pas été analysé comme il faut donc bah
voilà et tout ça ça c'est la totalité
des preuves à ce que je ne vous montrez
jeu j'aimerais j'aimerais insister
là-dessus ce que je viens de vous
montrer c'est la totalité des preuves
qu'on a pas d'épreuve entre guillemets
qu'on a une origine européenne de
l'humanité c'est tout et comme j'ai dit
j'ai fait une vidéo d'à peu près deux
heures pour montrer toutes les preuves
enfin une petite partie des preuves un
peu sélectionné qu'on a de l'origine
africaine de l'humanité donc si vous
voulez aller voir ça une fois de plus un
ça se passe dans mes cours de paléo
mammalogie ici et là j'explique en long
en large et en travers le magnifique
registre fossile avec les milliers de
fossiles qu'on a qui viennent d'afrique
qui nous montre que l'être humain est
originaire d'afrique
en plus des analyses génétiques qui
démontre ça aussi
donc bref en gros oui ça mérite un peu
le poil
ça mérite un peu le poil quand on me
parle encore d'une origine non
africaines de l'humanité non pas parce
que je suis un chien de garde mais parce
que les preuves sont mauvaises elles
sont mauvaises et elles n'ont pas été
analysés comme il faut et qu'on a beau
leur dire d'analyser ça mieux ils ne le
font pas enfin il
et quand je dit il je vais pas faire
comme lui c'est à dire désigné à isle
parce que ça va être encore de la
théorie du complot évidemment donc c'est
du cdu île où je désigne des les
chercheurs qui sont censés faire ça donc
les auteurs de tous ses papiers là c'est
des gens connus en plus généralement bon
le pain suis là pour le coup lui
l'époque au nul août
en tout cas moi je le connais pas mais
la voilà vous avez fut ce boom qui est
d'ailleurs dans le reportage sur arte
begun begun ces genres the autorité en
matière de grands singes fossile donc
c'est des gens c'est des gens qui ont de
la bouteille d'ailleurs vous retrouvez
begun ici et vous retrouvé vos meux ici
et fussent donc voilà ils sont c'est des
gens qui sont connues et d'ailleurs
c'est la même équipe 1 ouvrez vous faire
attention que les copies t cus et danube
youth c'est la même équipe
ce qui est aussi un bon indice de que de
quel genre de 2,2 de quel genre de
preuve on a quoi c'est à dire que les
preuves elles elles viennent l'analyse
de jean qui répète sans arrêt les mêmes
erreurs bon voilà à la limite il ya les
empreintes mais les empreintes ils sont
beaucoup moins catégorique là je là pour
le coup je connais personne mais dans
les empreintes au moins ils sont moins
catégoriques il éventuellement je crois
qu'ils disent ouais voilà il parle de
convergence évolutive où il parle où il
parle justement de distribution d eau
minines avant le pléistocène donc de
possibles migration donc là au moins ils
n'utilisent pas ces empreintes comme
preuve que l'humanité est né ailleurs
qu'en afrique
contrairement au reportage d'arte et qui
a dans lequel on voit boom madeleine
boom
donc voilà c'est c'est à dire que c'est
ce qu'on appelle une pseudo réplication
des données entre guillemets parce que
c'est pas exactement ça une pseudo
réplication mais en gros vous avez une
pseudo réplication c'est à dire que on a
l'impression de retrouver le même
résultat avec des protocoles différents
alors qu'en fait c'est plus ou moins le
même protocole qui a appliqué à chaque
fois c'est à dire que l'on va
analyser un fossile mais on va s'arrêter
au moment où on pourrait amener la
preuve qu'en fait ce que je dis depuis
le début c'est faux donc du coup c'est
facile d'arriver à la même conclusion à
chaque fois puisque à chaque fois on
prend la conclusion avant on fait notre
petit notre petit nos petites analyse
pour montrer qu'on a raison et puis au
moment où on fait l'analyse qui
pourraient montrer qu'on a tort à savoir
l' analyse phylogénétique bas on
s'arrête là et on a beau et j'ai eu beau
leur expliquer dans mon article
enfin dans notre article parce que je
suis pas tout seul à l'avoir écrit quand
même mais voilà on a eu beau leur
expliquer ça dans leurs artistes dans
cet article que bat pour démontrer une
origine africaine faudrait au moins
faire une analyse cladistique mais ils
n'ont pas fait ou une autre type d'
analyse phylogénétique je suis pas
sectaire
vous pouvez faire du bayésiens si ça
vous amuse un jeu c'est que les
paléoanthropologues ont tendance à pas
faire confiance à la khl a dit stick
mais la voilà le bail et bien c'est une
autre mode analyse phylogénétique qui
marche aussi
donc bref voilà je suis pas un chien de
garde peu je suis pas forcément un chien
de garde
mais par contre faut pas non plus
pousser mémé dans les orties les les
fossiles sont pas bons et enfin les
fossiles sont ou pas bon ou mal analysé
donc voilà la base on n'a même pas
encore commencé à parler de la vidéo
quoi ça fait déjà des caisses que je
parle et on n'a pas encore commencé même
à analyser la vidéo mais au moins vous
avez l'historique vous savez d'où je
viens
vous savez d'où je viens et dans quel
état d'esprit je suis en arrivant devant
une vidéo comme ça alors cette vidéo a
été publiée sur pagannes tv qui est une
qui est une chaîne dont sur pour
laquelle j'ai fait aucune recherche donc
je m'en fous totalement vous pourrez
tout à fait honnête c'est une chaîne qui
affiche le secret de l'atlantide ici qui
nous affiche un magnifique logo
francs-maçons là une vidéo sur les
pyramides une vidéo sur l'atlantide une
vidéo sur sur quoi d'autre les
hyperboréens bah oui c'est un manque et
et [ __ ] je grille mois voilà bon bref
on va arrêter d'explorer sa chaîne g1 ya
jacques grimaud jacques grimaud c'est la
révélation des pyramides ces genres le
le truc qui fait râler tous les tous les
étés titien depuis combien maintenant 10
ans 20 ans j'ai pu séquencer sortie
quand ce truc là s'est passé sur arte
aussi tiens donc voilà voilà de uche
démarre donc une vidéo d'un mec qui a
apparemment fait des vidéos sur sur les
mêmes bêtises que jacques grimaud bref
donc on va essayer quand même de rester
polis on va essayer de ne pas faire d'
attaque à nos mines m
bien que je sais que c'est pour ça que
vous êtes là je sais que vous êtes là
pour me voir m'énerver je vais quand
même essayer de pommes énervé allez ça
fait treize minutes
on croise les doigts on serre les fesses
c'est parti par contre le monsieur parle
très lentement alors je vais la regarder
en accéléré parce que ma douleur ma
tolérance à la douleur est là c'est
limite donc comme il parle très très
lentement et qui fait des longues pauses
entre ces phrases je la regardais en
accéléré les plus anciens hominidés
ancêtres européens
donc il a raison en parlant d'hominidés
parce que grec hôpitaux cus pourrait
plus ou moins être considéré comme un
hominidé tout dépend s'il se branchent
avec les gorilles et de chimpanzés ou
pas par contre ce qu'il montre là c'est
pas des hominidés céder aux mini ou deux
où est la limite des homininés mais bon
ça dépend enfin après les
classifications toute façon elles sont
toutes daube et je veux dire chacun a la
sienne
donc on va pas trop s'attarder là dessus
mais le truc l'idée que je veux faire
ressortir la c'est que il ya déjà il ya
une c'est très facile de faire une
confusion entre mini déo minini et
homininés et c'est parce que c'est
presque le même mot mais ça désigne des
choses différentes
le reportage d'arte et faisait cette
erreur et apparemment il n'a pas l'air
d'être au courant voilà c'est là où je
veux en venir
le reportage d'arte et sur lequel va se
baser sa vidéo comme
annoncé dans sa description d'ailleurs
j'ai pas vérifié il ya d'autres choses
ouais le reportage d'arte et et après
hachette ma merde oui c'est ça et
facebook et la boutique et les machins
vrai donc à celle est ma merde
bref donc bref le reportage d'arte et
sur lequel se basent apparemment sa
vidéo fait déjà cette confusion
monumental entre au mini et hominoïdes
donc au mini la lignée humaine et
hominoïdes les grands singes et donc la
lui commence par les hominidés en nous
montrant des eaux minini donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il va pas exactement
corriger cette confusion voire même il
va creuser
il va creuser archéologiques
voilà il a fait ses devoirs le monsieur
non il n'a pas fait ses devoirs le
monsieur l'archéologie
c'est l'étude des artefacts produit par
les humains ou les prêts humain où elle
et ruch d'avant encore même les
australopithèques apparemment même les
kenyans trope était capable de faire des
artefacts mais bref en tout cas
l'archéologie c'est ce qui est produit
par l'homme l'a pas les ondes là on
parle de paléontologie les squelettes en
eux-mêmes l'être humain en tant qu
entité biologique donc bon il n'y a pas
fait ses devoirs
y a pas fait ses devoirs déjà il n'a pas
fait ses devoirs sur la classification
il n'a pas fait ses devoirs non plus sur
ça ça va être long ça va être long il va
vraiment falloir que je m'arrête à
toutes les deux miss phrase quoi donc la
théorie out of africa
là pour le coup je trouve qu'elle est
relativement bien présente et c'est les
humains qui sont originaires d'afrique
bon la carte est un peu vieille
puisqu'elle met deux cent mille ans
maintenant on est entre deux cent mille
quatre cent mille ans voilà ça dépend
les fossiles et les analyses génétiques
que vous prenez en considération pour
faire votre carte
mais voilà l'être humain arrive ya à peu
près 40 millions en europe et sont
encore noir effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui a été démontré encore une fois
par des laze analyses génétiques
il ya effectivement beaucoup de gens qui
disent
c'est le bon sens parce que en afrique
et du soleil en europe y en a pas et si
vous voulez synthétiser de la vitamine d
vaut mieux être blanc en europe et noir
en afrique parce que noir en afrique
vous cramer si vous êtes blanc mais si
vous êtes noir en europe
vous finissez par avoir des problèmes de
synthèse osseuse parce que vous pouvez
pas faire de vitamine d parce que vous
êtes trop protéger du soleil
donc il ya cette histoire de bon sens
qui est souvent très défendu moi je
trouve que la meilleure la meilleure
preuve c'est les analyses génétiques
parce qu'on a des analyses génétiques
béton qui montre sa donc là par exemple
en voilà une parmi beaucoup d'autres qui
suggère que les êtres humains ont subi
des mutations rendant leur peau plus
claire en europe
d'abord il y a trente mille ans ici puis
encore d'autres mutations qui ont rendu
leur pour encore plus claire entre 11000
et 19000 en voilà sachant que la peau
humaine devait être foncé déjà depuis à
peu près 3 millions d'années les sages
enfin les grands singes comme les
chimpanzés ou l'impôt plutôt clair et ce
plat et c'est dû au pelage qui protège
la peau en fait sous le pelage la peau
est claire et le pelage a été perdue
apparemment les mutations qui ont causé
la perte du pelage elles ont eu lieu il
ya à peu près 3 millions d'années donc
ça fait à peu près 3 millions d'années
peut-être ou 2 millions d'années je sais
plus mais ça se compte en millions
d'années quoi donc en deux entre deux et
trois millions d'années on perd le
pelage en gros c'est aussi indiqué par
l'évolution des parasites l'évolution
des parasites de du pelage donc les poux
voilà nous nous humains avant deux
espèces de parasites du pelage l'époux
et les morpions et la divergence entre
enfin la séparation entre poux et
morpion elles datent aussi à peu près de
trois millions d'années
donc voilà ça veut dire que en gros le
torse est devenu une zone à berne à peu
près il ya trois millions d'années
puisqu'il faut bien qu'il ait séparation
des deux zones pour que la divergence
entre poux et morpion se fasse mais bref
c'est c'est entre deux et trois millions
d'années que ça s'est produit cette
perte du pelage donc c'est là qu'un
peuple que c'est probablement là que la
peau foncée est apparu on a des
mutations génétiques aussi qui rendent
la peau encore plus foncée et on l'a on
le sait il ya cinq cent mille ans donc à
peu près chez homo heidelbergensis et
donc après cette fausse cette peau
devient plus clair après une mutation il
ya trente mille ans et encore une fois
plus clair
il ya onze mille à dix neuf mille ans il
ya une nouvelle analyse génétique qui
n'est pas encore publié mais qui a l'air
de suggérer qu'il ya encore entre cinq
et huit mille ans les européens étaient
relativement fond c'est toujours donc le
problème c'est que la peau voilà
l'évolution de la mélanine et de la
couleur de la peau et des yeux et des
cheveux c'est pas juste une affaire
d'une mutation quoi c'est la sphère de
beaucoup de jeunes mais c'est une
histoire très compliquée mais on peut la
résumer ainsi quoi on peut la résumer
comme ça en gros les les humains sont
progressivement devenus de plus en plus
clair à partir du moment où ils sont
rentrés en europe
voilà et je sais même plus pourquoi
j'étais parti là dessus donc il nous dit
que là où tom africa c'est plus valide
la carte qui nous montre relativement
correct suivant vous savez cette belle
théorie bien pensants qui veut qu'on
vienne le mot bien pensants donc déjà on
injecte de la politique je vais même pas
m'arrêter dessus et blanc auraient été
noir et encore puis qu'ils auraient
blanchi
suite à leur migration vers l'europe
dont le climat est beaucoup moins
ensoleillé tout ça c'est une belle
histoire
battez généticien tu le sais mieux que
les généticiens voilà moi moi j'ai pop
moi j'ai preuves à l'appui article comme
j'ai dit c'est qu'un article mais vous
vous lisez l'introduction de cet article
là vous lisez la biblio qui est cité là
dedans et vous trouverez toutes les
références quoi donc voilà l'article est
disponible en ligne the timing
pigmentation lightning s'est démontrée
par des analyses génétiques c'est pas
seulement une histoire de climat voilà
c'est là où je voulais en venir aussi
c'est que l'histoire du climat c'était
une hypothèse à la base c'est une
hypothèse si la couleur de peau humaine
est dépendante du climat et notamment de
l'ensoleillement
alors on devrait voir diminution de la
pigmentation chez les européens en
fonction de leur migration en europe
enfin de l'homo sapiens en fonction de
sa migration en europe et ça a été
confirmé par les analyses génétiques à
partir de là tu peux dire ce que tu veux
fa tu peux tu peux dire ce que tu veux
mais si tu vas à l'encontre de ça c'est
toi qui est faux voilà basiquement
introduit par l'idéologie centriste dans
le paysage scientifique alors
l'idéologie affront centriste soit
disant prédominante dans le paysage
scientifique
on va se calmer un peu on va se calmer
un peu après ce que l'afrique c'est
encore un truc
comment dire à la façon dont l'afrique
est considéré dans le paysage
scientifique
on pourrait en débattre mais alors très
très longtemps et notamment des
chercheurs africains la façon dont les
chercheurs d'origine africaine sont
considérés par les scientifiques
européens ça aussi on peut en débattre
on est alors très très très longtemps
non non c'est pas si simple
c'est pas si simple et c'est le problème
quand tu es un gect comme ça delà de la
politique dans le mix c'est que tu te
mets affirmé des trucs alors que alors
que visiblement ce monsieur ne connaît
rien au milieu de la recherche puisque
pour lui arte est une source fiable
d'information donc pas les articles
scientifiques
donc voilà c'est là on efface voilà
c'est ce qu'il faut dire
sans aller traiter les gens dignes arr
etc
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que on est
face à quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas le
milieu de la recherche
c'est évident cette personne ne connaît
pas le milieu de la recherche et se
permet d'en faire une critique est ce
que moi je vais prendre le milieu dans
lequel 7 personnes travaillent voilà
quel que soit le quel que soit le le
domaine dans lequel travaillent sept
personnes est-ce que je vais prendre ce
corps de métier et juste des insultes et
de connard sans même savoir dans quoi
ibos je dire voilà je vais je vais
commencer à dire 'voilà ce monsieur je
ne suis pas d'accord avec lui je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ce qu'il dit donc le
corps métier de métier dans lequel il
travaille
c'est des ignares je ne veux même pas en
entendre parler c'est non c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche
si vous ne connaissez pas vous dit rien
c'est tout c'est simple
et non la théorie afrocentriste n'allait
pas si enfin je veux dire les les
scientifiques sont pas si afrocentriste
que ça quoi non non c'est juste qu'on a
les preuves
un point c'est tout on a les preuves des
milliers de fossiles et des analyses
génétiques et encore une fois alors
ignorance totale des analyses génétiques
ça va être long ça va être long une
minute 24
j'ai déjà j'ai déjà le pouls à 220 lieu
voilà quelqu'un se disait il connaît
rien il connaît rien parce qu'ils nous
appellent les archéologues alors c'est
des paléontologues qui est en train de
critiquer voilà il y connaît tellement
rien si vous partez du principe que
quelqu'un n'a pas besoin de connaître
pour critiquer un bon alors là on va
partir dans des cités ceci dit les
derniers débats qu'on a pu avoir sur
twitter sur sur internet montre que les
gens ne se gêne pas pour débattre de
choses dont ils ne connaissent rien donc
ma foi j'ai eu et puis encore une fois
cette accusation de bien pensants ce le
problème c'est que la bien-pensance
aller autant l'ennemi des paléontologues
et des archéologues puisqu'on va faire
un autre groupe la bien-pensance aller
autant l'heure et demie que leurs amis
je veux dire encore une fois est injecte
de la politique dans de la science ça
peut pas faire un mix qui fonctionne
parce que ben la bien pensante
elle fonctionne aussi contre les
archéologues par exemple quand les
archéologues nord américains ont trouvé
des restes de près de population
précolombienne qui datent d'entre 15000
et dix mille ans voilà c'est une
découverte absolument révolutionnaire
c'est une culture qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on appelle la
culture clovis et et pourtant il ya des
ja des communautés bien pensante qui se
sont dit que ce serait quand même
vachement bien que ce squelette ne soit
pas souillé par des scientifiques
occidentaux parce que la science est
fondamentalement occidental donc ce
serait bien que ces restes de squelettes
ne soit pas souillé par la culture
occidentale et retourne et soit enterrée
avec un enterrement de la religion qui
correspond à ceux à ce squelette
enfin la culture dans laquelle
appartenait ce serait donc refaire un
enterrement dans les rites sacrés que
sont les rites sacrés des populations
précolombiennes dawim eh ben oui mais
cette personne elle vivait entre 10000
et 15000 ans et elle avait une culture
différente de celle des populations
précolombiennes aujourd'hui ça n'a aucun
[ __ ] de sens de faire ça ça n'a aucun
[ __ ] de sens elle avait une religion
différente elle avait des croyances
différentes les rites funéraires étaient
différents
donc voila et ça c'est là bien pensants
ce qui a conduit à ça donc les
scientifiques ils ont eu les boules
alors je sais plus comment ça a fini
cette histoire je sais même plus la date
exacte du squelette
mais bref et voilà celle ci la
bien-pensance ça ne va pas que dans le
sens des scientifiques ça va aussi dans
le sens contraire des fois et à chaque
fois injecter de la politique dans ces
questions-là samoisy le débat là si
c'est par exemple la chine qui essayent
systématiquement de tirer l'origine
humaine vers la chine justement le truc
c'est qu'ils ont des moyens
donc ils sont capables de publier
beaucoup mais ils ont moins de fossiles
par contre alors du coup ils font des
extensions et là c'est pareil avec
l'europe c'est encore une histoire de
tirer la couverture vers l'europe alors
qu'il a quasiment pas de fossiles
pourquoi parce que les européens ils ont
plus de moyens que en afrique faut voir
qu'il n'ya quasiment pas de paléo
anthropologues africains en afrique
c'est c'est un truc de fou
les paléo anthropologues africains en
afrique on n'a quasiment pas il ya
quasiment aucune université qui forment
des palais ont des paléontologues en
afrique il y en a que peut-être deux ou
trois d'ailleurs c'est tout dans tout le
continent africain alors que rien qu'en
france vous en trouverez au moins trois
ou quatre des universités qui forment
des paléontologues et il ya au moins il
ya au moins poitiers et paris qui forme
des paléoanthropologues et ça c'est rien
qu'en france c'est pas à l'échelle d'un
continent entier donc
l'afro centrisme tamer quoi pas parce
que lui les parents parce que lui il a
pas une idéologie à racines politiques
genre genre il est capable de dire ça
sans froncer les yeux quoi avec strike
faith qu il est capable de dire ça sans
s'emplissait quoi lire c'est son
idéologie l est tout autant teinté de
politique que l'idéologie qu'ils
pourraient être contrecarrés donc si tu
commences à utiliser le fait que
l'idéologie soit teinté de politique
contre la théorie tu que tu n'aimes pas
je le dire tu peux tu peux tout à fait
retourner cet argument contre toi même
donc déjà ça c'est un mauvais argument
par cette idéologie politique c'est
pourquoi je tenais vraiment à saluer et
encourager la poignée de scientifiques
qui s'attachent à trouver la vérité en
dépit des conséquences négatives que
cela pourrait avoir sur leur carrière
c'est vrai que faire un reportage sur
arte ils ont quand même pris la fessée
cul nu a dit non parce que quand même
depuis c'est à dire qu'entre entre la
publication de greco pitt et cus en 2000
en 2010 en 2016 non reçus en 2016 publié
en 2010 est entre la publication de
greco pittacus en 2017 et un reportage
sur arte en 2020 c'est vrai qu'ils se
sont vachement fait botter le cul un
didon non parce que entre temps ils ont
juste ça c'était gréco pittacus 2010 7,1
mais entre temps ils ont publié danut
vieussan 2019 et ça c'est dans nature's
donc nature's ces genres la revue de
sciences la plus prestigieuse en tout
cas tu peux en tout cas quand et
paléontologue tu peux pas aller dans
plus prestigieux que ça après tu peux
publier dans ce land 7 qui est plus
prestigieux mais il ya que les médecins
qui publie dans ce land 7
mais voilà nietzsche il n'y a pas plus
prestigieux que ça les mecs le lien
c'est pas une descente aux enfers qu'ils
ont vécues a depuis gréco pitt et q5
ils sont passés de ils sont passés de
you chaîne fut ses madeleines bout me
tiens c'est qui ces gens là comme je
disais david bergen était un peu connu
ils sont passés à wow ces gens là encore
et maintenant ils ont un reportage sur
arte qui leur est dédié donc non ils
n'ont pas du tout vécu une des
quant aux enfers ils n'ont pas été mis
au ban de la société et encore moi au
ban de la communauté paléontologique
comme je les dis ils reçoivent des
critiques constructives de la part de
plusieurs personnes notamment de moi et
de mes collègues mais voilà c'est une
critique constructive qu'on a fait là
c'est une analyse cladistique en disant
que bah ouais ça manque dans votre truc
et ça aurait pu montrer que vous avez
tort voilà mais à aucun moment les a
ridiculisé en place publique aucun
moment même l'article que j'ai fait la
même l'article que j'ai écrit là ça
restées cordiales et tout à fait
scientifique n ya aucun moment où les
accuse de compétent compétents si à
aucun moment où on leur dit que c'est
des gros cons le dire ça reste des
critiques cordiale par contre dans les
commentaires la il ya des critiques pas
cordiale
là par contre on se fait insulter en
commentaire un petit peu bon pas un
petit peu enfin peut pas insulter
insulté il n'y a pas de gros mots mais
voilà on nous traite un peu de tous les
noms quand même donc ouais c'est ca
mitigé nouvelle logique qui permet de
démontrer à l'origine de l'humanité
ces scientifiques n'ont pas été aidés
par leurs confrères loin de là alors un
coup d'oeil à la publics grecs au pit
est qu un deux trois quatre personnes un
coup d'oeil à la publie sur dan eu lieu
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 personnes neuf co
auteur et je compte pas toute l'équipe
d'arte et ils ont pas aidés ils n'ont
pas été aidés à bon bah ça fait quand
même beaucoup de monde qui est pas aidé
un super et on a retrouvé les premières
traces fossilisées dans les années 40 80
mais c'est franchement aujourd'hui c'est
faux c'est totalement faux voici un
livre de 2015
et si je recherche grieco pittacus
en 2015 vous voyez que ce livre en
parlait déjà
donc c'est pareil c'est faux c'est juste
faux il ya eu une analyse qui a été fait
par bang khen xv halde en 1972 que qui
est citée ici il ya une analyse qui a
été fait par martine et andrews en 1984
donc voilà je veux dire il ya ce fossile
étaient connus les copies tqs je veux
dire pile à vous avez un livre de 2015
qui en rappelle l'existence donc avant
2017 et l'article qui a tout enflammer
sauf qu'avant il n'était pas considéré
comme étant proche de il n'était pas
considéré comme étant proche des
homininés parce que les restes sont
tellement fragmentaire je le rappelle
les restes sont tellement fragmentaires
et de mauvaise qualité qu'en fait on a
considéré qu'ils appartenaient à une
autre espèce qui s'appelle houran au pit
et cus voilà où hadopi tqs qui a la
caractéristique comme gréco pitt accuse
d'avoir une petite canine donc et qui
vivait en europe aussi donc houran au
pit et cus et gréco pittacus avant 2017
en fait c'était plus ou moins considéré
comme étant la même chose voilà c'est
pour ça qu'il est passé un peu sous le
radar mais et c'est aussi parce que les
restes étaient de mauvaise qualité
une fois de plus mais ils ont été
étudiées avant 2017 faut pas dit voilà
faut arrêter de dire de la merde comme
dirait comme dirait d'harry sérieux
la théorie du complot deux minutes 38 et
on y est déjà
mais tu l'a regardé au moins le
reportage d'arte et c'est s'est dit dans
le reportage d'arte et comment ça se
fait que ça a été perdue c'est juste
parce que le mec je sais plus l'histoire
exactement mais le mec est parti à la
retraite et puis on voit là ils ont tout
foutu dans un coin c'est tout que le mec
qui les avait il est parti à la retraite
où il est mort et puis ils ont tout
foutu dans un coin et le pire et le pire
c'est triste à dire mais le problème
c'est que ça arrive beaucoup plus
souvent qu'on imagine des gens qui
parlent qui partent à la retraite ou
qu'ils déménagent ou qui meurent et puis
bah tous les fossiles qu'ils ont dans
leur bureau ils laissent le bordel
derrière
quoi et puis ben du coup c'est perdu
enfin je veux dire on des mères on
déménage le bureau vite fait mal fait
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de places
dans les universités parce qu'il n'a pas
assez d'argent
donc il faut déménager les bureaux vite
fait mal fait pour pouvoir installer
d'autres personnes qui étaient déjà à 5
dans un autre bureau donc au moins
maintenant ils seront plus que trois es2
et mais le problème c'est que du coup
dans la foulée les fossiles qui étaient
dans des boîtes et notamment si on les
fout dans un tupperware bas suite à un
moment on va peut-être pas forcément
réalisé que c'était les fossiles mais
enfin les fossiles il n'était pas perdue
puisqu'on les a retrouvés enfin je veux
dire il était pas mal
ils n'ont pas été négligemment balancer
quelques part vu qu on a fini par les
retrouver
c'est juste que comme les restes sont
fragmentaires aussi et peut intéresser
quoi c'est tout et une fois de plus donc
non l'a appelé à la négligence je dis
oui c'est un peu de la négligence mais
dans le sens où c'est plus un problème
de moyens on va dire c'est pas tellement
un problème de volonté c'est un problème
de moyens c'est pas qu'on a voulu les
balancer dans un coin c'est que le
problème c'est que le bas
les paléontologues sont des êtres
humains et puis ben voilà des fois ils
meurent des fois il déménage des fois
ils partent à la retraite et puis bah si
si tu es le seul au monde à savoir où se
placent un fossile quelque part dans une
institution dans une collection
ben les grands et les gens ils passent
derrière toi ils regardent ils disent ça
va ou ça voilà tout ça tout ça dans un
coin là où ils peuvent coin qui n'est
pas là où il est censé être d'où la
perte entre guillemets voilà c'est pas
perdu c'est juste stocker ailleurs mais
c'est pas là où c'est censé être donc et
le problème c'est que c'est comme je
disais c'est pas si peu fréquent un
moi-même
moi même j'ai commencé en étudiant un
crâne de dauphin qui est resté dans un
tiroir pendant 15 ans pas plus tard
qu'il ya deux semaines je crois on
parlait d'un fossile de mozart d'un oeuf
de mozart et s'étoffe de noah zaz or je
vais montrer une petite image quand même
sept oeuvres de mozart il était gardé
dans un coin depuis 2011
je veux dire il a été il était pas perdu
il n'était pas voilà c'est pas qu'on a
négligé
c'est pas qu'on a voulu le cacher c'est
pas comme c'est pas parce qu il
révolutionner la paléontologie et
l'histoire de l'évolution
qu'on a voulu le cacher non c'est juste
parce que ben on savait pas quoi en
faire
donc on l'a mis dans un coin on l'a un
peu oublié depuis 2011
voilà et puis c'est presque par hasard
qu'on est retombé dessus enfin que que
le lucas et son superviseur sa
superviseure sont retombés dessus voilà
et du coup oui ça fait un bel article
après comme comme les copies t q cela on
la retrouvait ça a fait un bel article
c'est une histoire qui est hélas trop
classique mais rien de rien de qui un
rien que la musique là cette musique
d'x-files cette façon de dire on
l'aurait perdu
la négligence on l'aurait dissimulé
ça se trouve ça ça suggère une théorie
du complot non il n'y a pas de complot
c'est hélas trop fréquent a été retrouvé
tupperware qu'il était dans des
collections la raison pour laquelle il
était dans un tupperware sait qu un
tupperware
c'est vachement bien parce que c'est
hermétique donc on n'a pas de problèmes
trop de problèmes de circulation d'air
d'oxydation 2 et puis ce tupperware il
était fort et avec du coton encore une
fois regarde le truc art et il était
très bien enfin je veux dire
certes le choix du tupperware n'est pas
académique mais c'est quand même un bon
choix pour pouvoir stocker un fossile
il ya beaucoup de faux cils qui sont
stockés ils ont même pas droit à un
tupperware hélas ils ont ils sont
balancés comme ça dans les tiroirs et à
chaque fois que tu ouvre le tiroir le
fossile y roule donc à chaque fois ils
s'usent même si tu mets de la mousse au
fond du tiroir tu ouvre le tiroir le
fossile y rouler salue donc ce fossile
il a quand même eu le droit à un
traitement de faveur avec ce super war
on peut voir le verre à moitié vide mais
faut voir aussi que le vert il est
plutôt plein en fait quelle étrange
histoire mais s'expliquer dans le
reportage arte s'est expliqué il retrace
toute l'histoire
dans le reportage art
et [ __ ] c'est le reportage qui est
sensé voilà vous allez sur sa vidéo vous
cliquez là et vous avez la réponse à sa
question là on saura jamais pourquoi si
on saura pourquoi c'est tout expliqué
dans le reportage que cet artefact
proton a permis de démontrer que le plus
ancien réseau l'unité est originaire de
grèce la copie tech dont on a retrouvé
d'autres traces en bulgarie et non pas
en crête en crête c'est les empreintes
de pas et c'est pas gris copie tech
puisque elles sont 2 5 millions d'années
donc ça voudrait dire que la copie tech
a vécu entre 7 et 5 millions d'années ça
fait un peu long c'est pas impossible
mais ça fait un peu long et puis il ya
encore une fois gréco phitek c'est une
petite mâchoire donc pour moi pour dire
que des empreintes appartiennent à une
mâchoire faut avoir de l'imagination
quand même qu'ils sont faux c'est faux
et voici la preuve ici l'article d'en
publier dans pnns où ils ont utilisé
diverses méthodes de datation pour dater
les dépôts ou to my way a été trouvé et
où il trouve que toumaï et daté d'entre
donc sahelanthropus tchadensis aide à
tête entre 6,8 et 7,2 millions d'années
ce qui recouvre totalement la datation
de greco pitt et cus à celle de 7,1
séduit 2 millions d'années
donc non c'est pareil c'est on ne peut
pas exclure que toumaï soit du même âge
que gréco pitt accuse donc ça prouve
rien voilà la suite
ces empreintes de pas n'appartiennent
pas à gré copie tech
elles n'appartiennent pas à gréco pitt
est qu'elles sont deux millions d'années
plus jeunes 5,7 faut être précis
quand on commence à jouer avec des
différences d'âge il faut être précis le
ramener ses empreintes à 6 millions
d'années ça les rapproche degré copie
tech ça t'arrange bien mais non c'est
5,7
découverte relayé par la chaîne de
télévision arte ne remettra cependant
pas rose ni la théorie de l'évolution
ni la théorie de l'origine commune à
toute l'humanité
c'est quoi cette mauvaise foi c'est à
dire que le mec il vendrait son âme quoi
il est il est là en train de nous
expliquer que la théorie de l'évolution
montre que les humains sont pas
originaires d'afrique mais alors s'il
trouvait un reportage qui disait qu'il
n'y a pas de théorie d'évolution du tout
il serait complètement prêt à retourner
sa veste
[Rires]
c'est juste il est il et il est
tellement pressé de vouloir trouver des
trucs qui défient l'autorité
enfin c'est fou quoi c'est fou d'être
pas logique à ce point il est tellement
avide de trouver des trucs qui remettent
en question le scénario établi
enfin ceux qui dans sa tête et le
scénario établi que que du cool s'ils
trouvaient quelque chose qui dit en fait
l'évolution c'est faux bah il se
jetteraient dessus bien que juste avant
il vous est expliqué que la théorie de
l'évolution montre que le quel humain
n'est pas originaire d'afrique
je veux dire ce ça reste arte mais arte
ils ont diffusé des conneries je veux
dire ils ont dit ils ont diffusé
tellement de choses qui veut qu'il irait
dans le sens de ce genre de délire quoi
ils ont diffusé l'espèce de reportages
sur les géants que j'avais déjà débarqué
dans un autre des bonnes kg pénitence
d'ailleurs ils ont dit ce qu'ils ont
diffusé à l'ère des p je veux dire à
repérer ils ont diffusé des diffuser des
tartines de daube faut voir quoi ils ont
diffusé cette espèce de reportages
créationnistes sur sur la lys fait nos
idées je me rappelle plus exactement
c'était ça avait fait polémique à
l'époque je veux dire arte ils sont tout
sauf consensuel quoi hein loin de là je
veux dire ils sont je crois même qu'ils
sont moins consensuel maintenant cui qui
peut dire c'est pour dire c'est que
wikipedia au moins ils ont des gens qui
nettoie le brun une fois de temps en
temps alors que arte
clairement il je sais pas qui est la
ligne éditoriale fait pas gaffe tout le
temps ça c'est clair donc non non non
c'est fou ça et je suis sûr que je suis
sûr que quand il fut le wec entre arte
diffuse un truc qui remet en question
l'ordre établi alors là tout de suite
c'est les héros national nationaux
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs quand on en parle
je veux dire art essai des héros
nationaux pour avoir diffusé le
reportage et et en même temps c'est des
connards parce qu'ils ont pas remis à
ces en question quoi serait ce serait
long c'est beau ça paint mon ami paint
mon ami dessine-moi une dispersion des
humains en dehors de l'europe selon les
principes de la théorie de l'évolution
il oriente si oui oui mais encore une
fois c'est les alors oui si les humains
étaient sortis d'europe pour aller en
afrique
il aurait noirci éventuellement on sait
que c'est l'armée mais encore une fois
ça se verrait sur les analyses
génétiques et c'est pas le cas les
analyses génétiques
elle montre clairement que le gros de la
diversité génétique humaine est en
afrique et que le reste de la diversité
génétique dans le monde
c'est juste un petit échantillon de la
diversité africaine qu'on retrouve
ailleurs et qui s'est diversifiée à
partir de ça donc je veux dire voilà il
n'ya pas y a pas à tortiller du cul sur
l'origine africaine de l'humain de homo
sapiens en tout cas le truc c'est
qu'encore une fois on est sur un sur une
contradiction on est sur une
contradiction entre la dispersion d'homo
sapiens et la dispersion des hominidés
gréco pittacus c'est une histoire de 10
provinces même pas des hominidés céder
aux minimes et gréco pittacus ce serait
une dispersion des homininés de l'europe
à l'afrique
alors que l'histoire d'homo sapiens et
du noircissement de napo en général
c'est une histoire d'homo sapiens c'est
pas une histoire qui se colle qui est
collée aux mini c'est une histoire qui
est collé homo sapiens
donc mais bon bref on a déjà souligné
que cette confusion là allait être fait
en long en large et en travers donc
quand il a vu ça manon maintenant
puisqu'on a déjà toumaï a longtemps
empêché je reviens en arrière je reviens
en arrière parce que cette phrase là
elle est quand même fort de café
d'après les immigrés en afrique que bien
après l'apparition gréco non c'est parce
qu'ils disent c'est parce qu'ils disent
du tout déjà les scientifiques qui ont
publié les empreintes de pas à eux ils
disent que c'est bel et bien à d'afrique
en europe que ça c'est fait la
dispersion ils remettent pas en question
et de deux les scientifiques qui eux et
de 2d c'est pas enfin fonds peut pas
dire que les que c'est bien après créé
copie tech qu'ils auraient migré puisque
même si on part du principe que des
copies tech est réellement l'ancêtre des
homininés toumaï et contemporain donc la
migration elle a quasiment lieu à vendre
et copie tech en fait puisque toumaï et
contemporain donc soit elle a eu lieu
juste après y copie tech ou en même
temps ou juste avant mais pas longtemps
après ça c'est sûr je veux dire c'est
mathématiquement pas possible grand
désert du sahara qui n'existait pas à
l'époque
batum haye on est la preuve je veux dire
tout mal il a été trouvé au beau milieu
du tchad y avait une forêt à ce temps
voilà donc le désert du sahara
n'existait pas à l'époque et on le sait
on a les fossiles en à l'épreuve le
sahara il est il est apparu bien après
bien bien après enfin il ya eu des
phases où il est apparu des phases où il
a disparu mais en gros le
pareil à sept millions d'années en tout
cas à sept millions d'années il n'y
avait pas de ça quelques changements
climatiques qui permet enfin de
rejoindre l'afrique en passant par le
moyen-orient et c'est donc à ce moment
après le changement climatique que les
premiers hominidés arrive dans la fri et
cela corrobore les datations découvert
deux africains plus récente donc ce
qu'ils négligent totalement ce qu'on
appelle la crise me signale donc encore
une fois son scénario ce que je veux
dire encore une fois son scénario il
tient même pas de bull dont je vais
remettre l'image histoire qu'on l'ait à
l'écran son scénario qui dit que
originaires d'europe donc autour de la
grèce puis dispersion dans l'afrique par
le moyen-orient ce scénario ignore
totalement le simple fait que il ya 5
millions d'années il n'y avait pas de
méditerranée entre les deux là donc je
veux dire si dispersion il ya eu entre
l'europe et l'afrique c'est plus
probablement à ce moment-là et
directement à travers la méditerranée il
ya 5 millions d'années la méditerranée
n'existe pas et on a la preuve que des
espèces ont traversé la méditerranée
notamment des rongeurs
pourquoi des rongeurs c'est pas parce
qu'on est plus intéressé par les
rongeurs c'est juste parce que les
rongeurs il fonce ils sont tellement
nombreux qu'on n'en trouve plus donc on
a des preuves directes que des rongeurs
ont traversé la méditerranée et après on
a des preuves supposé d'autres espèces
qui aurait traversé la méditerranée au
même moment mais moins directe il ya
notamment les au recteur up par exemple
les dames en aussi qu' on est traversé à
l'époque la méditerranée donc ce
scénario de dispersion c'est juste parce
qu'il a eu la flemme de faire ses
recherches encore une fois parce que ce
monsieur ne connaît rien à la
paléontologie
comme je lé déjà souligné il a eu la
flemme de faire des recherches donc il a
fait la route directement en passant par
le moyen-orient sur la carte qui connaît
le mieux c'est-à-dire la carte du monde
d'aujourd'hui et puis après ils à
trouville a essayé de d'internet de
google et des preuves de son petit
scénario a posteriori en fait ça se
reconstitue très bien ça comme mode de
pensée parce que cela ça se voit je le
dire un
donc s'il avait google est un peu plus
longtemps il aurait découvert qu'il ya
une crainte ruc qui s'appelle la crise
messinienne qui a eu lieu il ya 5
millions d'années et que gregory pincus
s'il avait dû traverser enfin que les
descendantes des copies tqs s'il avait
dû traverser la méditerranée ça aura été
à pied sec à ce moment là ça aurait été
beaucoup plus logique mais bref passons
cadre de la mission
il y aurait comme seule source car seuls
les origines de l'humanité sont
multiples et contre elle
différentes sources alors on va rentrer
dans le passage où justement on
ressuscite le modèle multi régional je
dirais suicide parce qu'il est mort et
enterré le modèle multi régional
il ya comme je lé dia qu'il n'y a plus
qu'un seul scientifique qui réellement
le soutien aujourd'hui c'est walt pauvre
il est pas tout jeune donc c'est un le
modèle multi régional comme beaucoup de
théories va certainement disparaître
avec ce monsieur
mais bref on n'est pas là pour parler de
ça on n'est pas là pour dire voilà le
modèle multi régional donc son problème
déjà il a un gros problème c'est qu'il
est pétri du racisme du 17ème 18ème et
19ème siècle enfin surtout du 19e siècle
pour être tout à fait honnête mais voilà
il est pétri de racisme c'est à dire
qu'on ne pouvait même pas envisagée à
l'époque de toute façon qu'ils avaient
une origine commune à toute l'humanité
comme les siècles précédents d'ailleurs
je veux dire c'est pour ça que j'ai
inclus le xviie siècle pour y inclure
tous les siècles avant ça il n'était
même pas question d'envisager une
origine commune à l'humanité à l'époque
de 2 ce modèle multi régional il ne
résiste pas au fait qu'on trouve
quasiment tous les fossiles de dôme un
dumas en afrique que ce soit de la
lignée humaine de sahel entre opus à
homo heidelbergensis où que ce soit des
premiers homo sapiens les premiers
fossiles
ap les homo sapiens ont découvert aussi
en afrique certes certains sont même
d'ailleurs plus contestée que d'autres
comme quand on parle par exemple de des
crânes de ma des crânes qui ont des gros
boulet pour les suces orbitaire et pas
de menton comme celui de
de djebel est rude c'est un crâne qui
est à peine homo sapiens ils ont d il ya
des signes d'homo sapiens dedans mais
c'est des crânes qui sont à peine homo
sapiens ce qui montre bien que c'était
des homo sapiens extrêmement archaïque
que seaway ce qui montre bien que si on
devait les rattacher homo sapiens se
seraient des homo sapiens extrêmement
archaïque et ce et ça c'est bien la
preuve qu'ils ont évolué à partir
d'autres choses qui étaient déjà
présents en afrique à cet endroit là
donc voilà je veux dire on l'a cette
documentation la de la lignée humaine
comme quoi l'afrique c'est la boîte de
pétri où toutes les expérimentations de
sur l'évolution de l'humanité ont eu
lieu c'est la boîte de pétri
alors après quand on est homo erectus
est sorti d'afrique à partir de là on
commence à voir une diversité se
développer en asie mais seulement à
partir de là à partir de deux millions
d'années
jeudi deux millions d'années parce qu'on
a des restes de doughty qui ont été
trouvés en chine qui ont de 2,1 millions
d'années donc
donc ça veut dire que homo erectus était
probablement déjà là sinon il y aurait
pas d'outils mais les preuves formelles
sinon les crânes ont les à 1,8 million
d'années en géorgie mais voilà à partir
de deux millions d'années on commence à
avoir un nouveau centre d'évolution qui
est l'asie et seulement à partir de
entre on va dire je crois à partir à
partir de 1,5 million d'années je crois
en europe c'est 1,8
il me semble mais à partir de la 5
millions d'années on commence aussi à
avoir un petit peu d'humains en europe
donc des homo erectus aussi qui sont
allés en europe et qui localement vos
données duel dahlberg n 6 du antécécent
or jusqu'à atteindre scellé près
néandertaliens en fait donc jusqu'à
donner naissance à néandertal donc c'est
un joyeux bordel mais on s'y retrouve
quoi origines africaines dispersion en
asie dispersion en europe voilà c'est le
problème là c'est que et ça c'est juste
les fossiles après on a les analyses adn
donc les analyses adn ça ne concerne que
homo sapiens et les analyses adn comme
je le disais met la plus grosse partie
de la diversité en afrique ce qui montre
bien que comme je le disais c'est la
boîte de pétri de l'humanité c'est là
que les expériences évolutive ont lieu
et que cette boîte de pétri il ya un
petit bout de cette boîte de pétri qui
est partie se promener en en asie et a
donné toute la diversité des autres
humains et ça ça se retrace très bien
par des analyses génétiques et comme je
le disais le problème du multi régional
c'est que c'est pétri de racisme cette
théorie c-26 c'est indissociable du
racisme en réalité c'est on pourrait
bien la re scientificité mais le
problème c'est qu'elle est née dans le
racisme
elle est née dans la distinction qu'on
peut faire sur la couleur de peau entre
européens asiatiques et africains et le
problème c'est que ces distinctions de
couleur de peau faut bien comprendre
qu'elles n'ont aucune valeur biologique
si ce n'est une adaptation à
l'ensoleillement
elles n'ont aucune valeur biologique on
pourrait hélas là c'est très important
parce qu'il ya enfin je veux dire il ya
beaucoup de théories raciales qui ont
été développés au fil des siècles
je veux dire le racisme n'a aucun sens
parce que les populations humaines qu'on
peut individualisé grâce aux analyses
adn donc ce qu'on pourrait appeler des
races en étendant le concept de race aux
populations génétique ce qui a été fait
je veux dire par le passé il ya des gens
qui ont théorisé qu'une population une
population isolée génétiquement pouvait
être appelé une race donc on a des
populations génétique humaine ce qui
fait que quand vous faites des analyses
adn on peut plus ou moins dire de quelle
région venez vos ancêtres
ça marche moins bien avec les européens
parce que l'europe c'est un joyeux
bordel où tout le monde sait mixer mais
ça marche alors relativement bien si
vous venez d'amérique du nord d'amérique
du sud
enfin si vos ancêtres viennent
d'amérique d'asie de d'indonésie
d'océanie enfin bref ça marche
relativement bien sûr des populations
qui ont pas trop bouger on va dire les
européens ça marche beaucoup moins bien
parce que ça a beaucoup bougé mais bref
ce que là où je veux en venir c'est que
on peut parler de races
en prenant ces populations isolées en
mettant des grosses guillemets encore
une fois mais on pourrait appeler ça des
races par comparaison aux autres animaux
tout simplement je veux dire pourquoi le
concept de race s'appliquerait aux
autres animaux et pas à l'homme voilà
c'est l'homme est un humain enfin
l'homme est un animal comme un autre
donc on pourrait lui appliquer le
concept de race mais le problème c'est
que ce concept de race basé sur la
génétique ne se superposent absolument
pas sur les couleurs de peau
il n'a rien à voir avec les couleurs de
peau 1
un indonésien donc un aborigène
d'australie même prenez un indonésien ou
un aborigène d'australie en importe est
plus proche de nous phylogénétiquement
plus proche des européens
phylogénétiquement que ne le sont un
soul ou et un bushmen
c'est à dire que le zoulou elle bushmen
ils vivent dans le même pays en afrique
du sud
ils sont plus distants génétiquement que
ne le sont un aborigène d'australie et
un européen
pourquoi bas parce que comme je les dis
il n'y a qu'un petit bout de la
diversité africaine qui s'est détaché du
coeur évolutif africains et qui a donné
tout le reste de la diversité c'est
qu'une seule population enfin une seule
vague de migration en réalité il y en a
eu 2 mai la première a pas donné grand
chose mais voilà il ya une grosse vague
de migration qui a donné toute façon les
deux vagues de migrations venait des
mêmes populations au nord-est de
l'afrique
donc au final ils avaient la même
signature génétique donc voilà ça a
donné tout le reste c'est cette
signature génétique qu'on retrouve
partout ailleurs ce qu on appelle ça des
apps le groupe
mais voilà c'est donc cette ce concept
de race qui est intimement liée à la
théorie multirégional ne vaut rien du
tout ce concept de race basé sur les
couleurs de peau qui fait dire aux gens
il ya une race européenne une race
asiatique une race africaine est une
race american si vous voulez ce concept
de race basé sur la couleur de peau qui
est au coeur de la théorie multirégional
ne vaut rien du point de vue génétique
du point de vue génétique on voit des
sous populations humaines qui ne se
superposent pas ça du point de vue
génétique il y a des milliers de race
noire et il ya des races encore une fois
entre guillemets il ya des milliers de
race noire et il y à quelques races
partout ailleurs dans le monde
parce que la diversité génétique est
gigantesque et juste appeler cette
diversité génétique des noirs ça ne veut
rien dire si on se met à ignorer cette
diversité génétique juste pour une
adaptation alors sur l'aliment
je suis désolé on n'est plus dans la
science on est dans les temps du racisme
parce que de toute façon il n'y a pas
d'autres motivations
y'a pas d'autres motivations de
persister à vouloir appeler les
populations par leur couleur de peau que
du racisme parce que biologiquement ça
n'a aucun [ __ ] de sens digression fini
c'est juste pour dire que là tout ce
qu'il va dire ça va être de la merde
voilà tout ce qui de tout ce qui peut
balancer la dans les prochaines minutes
ça va être nul parce que c'est pas
possible que tu puisses encore soutenir
le modèle multi régional en sachant tout
ce que je vais me dire et tout ce que je
viens de dire c'est factuel
c'est des analyses génétiques qui ont
montré ça je veux dire y'a pas depuis
depuis les années 90 même avant ça je
veux dire il ya je peux pas vous montrer
une publication parce qu'il ya pas une
publication qui sait il ya des milliers
de publications qui ont montré la même
chose par des équipes différentes qui
ont été confirmés péter répéter je veux
dire on a fait en début on n'avait qu'un
seul gène et on s'est dit tiens c'est
bizarre et au début on a après on en a
eu deux trois tralala maintenant on a
des génomes entiers de milliers de
personnes 10 races et tu veux quoi de
plus la théorie multi régional est morte
donc à part regarder des détails
spécifiques sur des petits fossiles
isolé machin comme par exemple le fait
que les chinois ils ont comme homo
erectus ils ont les dents les incisives
en forme de cuillère et ça ça a été un
des gros argument pour dire que les
chinois ils étaient attachés homo
erectus et pas homo sapiens et non enfin
les chinois les l'extrême orient
les populations extrême orientale et
donc ça a été un des gros argument pour
dire les les populations extrême
orientale sont issus de mourir actu ce
oui non c'est une convergence évolutive
parce qu'en fait le fait d'avoir les
dents en forme de cuillère sont attachés
sur les chromosomes à une autre à un
autre gène donc physiquement attaché sur
le chromosome à un autre gène et que
sept autres gènes en fait c'est une
adaptation au froid
voilà donc c'est l'adaptation au froid
qui fait qu'on a les mêmes c'est
l'adaptation même climat à la rigueur du
climat notamment en mongolie je suppose
qui fait que qui fait qu'ils ont la même
morphologie
voilà et c'est parce que ce gène
donc l'adaptation la morphologie des
incisives n'est pas une adaptation
froisser le gène auquel il est attaché
sur le chromosome en fait
et du coup ils évoluent ensemble les
deux jeunes alors qu'ils n'ont rien à
voir
la magie de la génétique bah oui mais ça
évidemment ça évidemment faut se
renseigner
ça sort pas de nulle part quand on quand
on connaît déjà pas la différence entre
archéologues et paléontologues je
m'attends pas évidemment est ce que
quelqu'un
enfin je m'attends pas à ce que
quelqu'un qui sait pas la différence
entre archéologues et paléontologues
sache ça va évidemment se résume en deux
on va dire que c'est par souci de
vulgarisation qui disent on va dire que
c'est par souci de simplification
bon bah on va on va dire que 1
on va pas commenter sur la nation sur le
fait que ce que c'est une simplification
outrageante ensuite on a eu dix huit ans
ça va être dur ça va être dur quand même
à fermer les yeux là dessus le type homo
sapiens le type au mot et le type
hominidés allez on fait maintenant on va
aller on va pas se mettre
voilà si vous voulez en savoir plus
allez voir la vidéo sur l'évolution des
homininés là vous aurez du détail mais
c'est vrai que dans une vidéo de 13
minutes il peut pas tout réexpliquer
donc on va dire que c'est vraiment par
souci de simplification ça fait mal aux
oreilles mais on va dire ça fait saigner
les oreilles mais on va dire que c'est
par souci de simplification
je suis homo sapiens et homo sapiens
mais le plus ancien humain doté est
intelligent c'est le tic aux homos de
cours et il a également été retrouvée en
grèce il s'agit de l'arc en europe
il est âgé de huit cent mille ans a été
découvert par le docteur l'arc entre up
l'arc en europe ça n'existe plus on
appelle ça un homme de néandertal donc
je peux vous montrer le crâne dont car
quand europe c'est le petit nom qu'on a
donnée au crâne de pétra l'ona donc le
crâne de pétrole menace et un crâne
qui a été découvert donc en grèce dans
la grotte de pétra l'ona comme ils
l'expliquent
et voici le crâne en question et ce
crâne
il a un volume crânien relativement
faible mais il a tous les caractères
d'un néandertalien donc ils allaient
bourrelet sus orbitaire le regard le
regard plutôt neutre si vous aussi vous
avez vu ma vidéo sur les sur l'évolution
humaine
je vous avais donné un petit ips à la
différence entre les deux bergen 6
néandertal et sapiens c'est que sapiens
les orbites qui ont l'air triste
néandertal a les yeux neutre et dahlberg
ensisa les yeux en colère donc si on
regarde le boulet le bourrelet sus
orbitaire là il est plutôt neutre il est
très pro éminents comme celle d'albert
guentis mais il est plutôt neutre le
front et fuyant comme un néandertal et 1
et d'albert gagnent 6
et ici on a les joues enfin les arcade
zygomatique qui ne forme pas un angle
mais qui forment plutôt un petit un
petit dénivelé comme ça ça c'est pareil
c'est une différence assez nette entre
néanderthal et l'homme moderne donc ici
chez l'homo sapiens on aurait un angle
et là on a plutôt un peu un léger petit
léger peu légère petite inclination donc
tout indique que ce truc là est relié à
néandertal à part le volume du crâne qui
est relativement faible pour un
néandertal je crois qu'il est de mille
deux cent mille cent ou mille 200
centimètres cubes néandertal en moyenne
il est plutôt à mille cinq cent mille
quatre cent mille 500 un petit peu plus
grand que sapiens est ce qui est c'est
ce qui fait qu'il est considéré comme
étant un ancêtres de néanderthal ce
qu'on appelle un prêt néandertaliens
donc des fois on y inclut et dahlberg n
6 dans ces prêts néandertaliens on y
inclut aussi en tc sort par exemple mais
voilà donc tout ça c'est ça on incluant
tc sort avec la petite nuance que des
analyses génétiques récentes ont l'air
de contredire que ses antécédents
l'ancêtre de néandertal mais bref voilà
c'est ça fait ces prêts néandertaliens
sakri cette morphologie de crâne cri le
pré néandertaliens à arc entre opus ça
n'existe plus
arc entre opus c'est le nom qu'on avait
donné à ce truc là au début parce que le
mec qui l'a découvert avais aucune idée
de ce qui était l'homme de néandertal je
suppose
j'en sais rien je suis pas allé voir
jusque là mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
il est universellement et
consensuellement considéré comme étant
un néandertal donc tout ce qui pourra
dire sur arc entre opus à partir de là
ça a été invalidée depuis les années 60
oui ça dérangeait pas ce que c'était un
néandertal et rien d'autre faut arrêter
de dire faut arrêter de vouloir à chaque
fois appelé la théorie du complot ça a
dérangé les gens parce que c'était fosse
était factuellement faux c'était un
néandertal on est en grèce il ya des
néandertal cet endroit là à ce moment là
enfin c'est un prêt néandertaliens
pardon donc non voilà donc vous le
trouverez sous le nom de néandertal vous
le trouverez sous le nom d'el dahlberg
m6 mais vous le retrouverez plus jamais
sous le nom de l'arc entre opus parce
que sa recontre opus ça n'existe pas
c'est un valide et c'est un synonyme de
néandertal m6 ou de haendel bergin six
en fonction de qui veut un qui vous
parlez non seulement l enrichir la
théorie out of africa
puisque cet homo se trouvait déjà en
europe dix ans alors que la théorie
c'est totalement faux hélas pour lui ça
aurait pu être un bon argument s'il
n'avait pas confondu au mot la sortie
d'afrique domo avec la sortie d'afrique
d'homo sapiens comme je l'aï expliqué
tout à l'heure il ya eu deux sortis
d'afrique il ya eu la sortie d'afrique
d'homo erectus qui est allé s'installer
en asie et qui est allé s'installer en
europe et c'est cet homo erectus
européen qui a donné les prêts en et
néandertaliens dont le crâne de petra
lovas et les néandertal et c'est
seulement plusieurs millions d'années
après deux millions d'années plus tard
que homo et a de nouveau sorti d'afrique
sous la forme d' homo sapiens donc là il
fait juste une erreur de deux millions
d'années
en confondant la sortie de domo et la
sortie d' homo sapiens c'est pas une
petite erreur 1 on va pas commencer à me
dire que c'est négligeable 2 millions
d'années
à cette échelle là c'est absolument pas
négligeable de millions d'années donc
non non la sq il y adeux dire c'est
factuellement faux la sortie des hommes
d'afrique
il y en a eu deux et ce crâne de pétra
l'ona va totalement enfin rentre
totalement dans le modèle de la sortie
de d'afrique d'homo erectus et d'homo
erectus évoluant localement pour donner
les prêts néandertaliens et néandertal
vous les appelez l2 le bergen cissé
antécécent or si vous voulez ça après
c'est des débats taxonomique c'est entre
spécialistes et en plus c'est tout bon
sens jour à une petite blague homophobe
une petite blague homophobe parce que ça
ça manquait
ça manquait qui contredit l'idée sur
laquelle tous horizons viennent
d'afrique
et puis qu'est ce qui montre qu est ce
qui montre qu'il était blanc je veux
dire même moi je veux bien admettre
qu'il était blanc c'était un prêt
néandertaliens les néandertaliens
étaient majoritairement blancs encore
que encore une fois des analyses
génétiques ont suggéré que les
néandertaliens qui vivaient plutôt en
méditerranée tour de la méditerranée et
notamment au proche orient
puisqu'il ya eu des néandertaliens au
proche orient c'est même là que homo
sapiens et néandertal se sont libres
idée c et néandertaliens devait avoir la
peau plus foncée
déjà c'est logique parce qu'il fait plus
ensoleillés et en plus les analyses
génétiques ont suggéré qu'ils avaient la
peau plus foncée donc donc déjà c'est
quoi le type blanc c'est quoi le
pourquoi tu dis que c'est un homo de
type blanc enfin c'est à dire qu'en gros
là il est même il n'est pas seulement en
train de dire que
voici ces cons c'est cohérent avec son
modèle multi régional c'est à dire qu'en
fait être blanc prévaut par dessus tout
voilà donc toutes les différences qu'il
ya entre homo sapiens et l'homme de
néandertal donc les bourgs les suces
orbiteur la forme ovale du crâne la
forme de rares cas de gale la dentition
la mâchoire qui est plus proéminente le
nez qui est plus large le la forme du
corps qui est plus trapu qui est plus
bas aussi qui est plus courant fin qui
est moins haut
comment je peux plus tu as et voilà tout
c'est différent cela en fait sont
complètement effacée par le fait que la
peau est blanche
voilà non ça ne marche pas comme ça
là encore avec non elle ne l'est pas
elle ne l'est pas du tout avec un
fossile encore une fois la recette si on
est sur deux un exemple typique mais de
cherry picking c'est à dire qu'on a des
milliers de fossiles on va prendre celui
qui m'arrange
en plus il n'arrange même pas je veux
dire c'est à dire que là il est
tellement mal renseigné la lave vous
sortir un truc qu'il aurait dû sortir à
ce moment là c'est à dire que je vais
lui apprendre à faire son boulot il
aurait dû vous parlez d'un fossiles
d'homo sapiens se trouvait en grèce et
apparemment vieux de 200 mille ans voilà
il aurait dû vous parler de cet article
là dans la grotte d'api dima s'il avait
voulu vraiment brillé s'ils avaient
vraiment voulu me [ __ ] dans la merde
voilà clairement s'ils avaient vraiment
voulu que je fasse pas mon chien de
garde et que je dise brune cette
personne sait de quoi il parle il aurait
fallu qu'ils me parlent de cet article
cet article là dans la grotte d'api dima
en grèce montre enfin suggère qu'il y
avait un homo sapiens en grèce il y a
deux cent mille ans et moi si je me
rappelle bien la date c'est de web à la
210 millions il ya deux cent dix mille
ans et ça effectivement au niveau de la
sortie d'afrique d'homo sapiens ça fout
la merde parce que homo sapiens n'est
pas censé être sortis d'afrique avançant
milan est donc là éventuellement ça
suggérait que dix ans il y avait au most
là il pourrait contorsionner le truc
jj je dirais a encore une fois il
faudrait ignorer les fossiles et les
analyser il faudrait ignorer tous les
autres fossiles et toutes les analyses
génétiques mais il pourrait contentieux
né le truc en dix ans
voilà api dima hilde api dima un ici il
suggère ce fossile là il suggère que
homo sapiens était déjà présent en
europe avant d'être présent en afrique
ce qui n'est pas vrai mais il y avait
déjà des le plus vieux homo sapiens et
celui de djebel route comme je disais
tout à l'heure et il a trois cent mille
ans c'est un homo sapiens archaïque là
on est sur un homo sapiens sa forme
plutôt moderne apparemment vu la forme
du crâne mais encore une fois on a que
l'arrière d'un crâne
donc on n'a que un bout de bois de
crânienne c'est pas non plus la folie
mais ce bout de boîte crânienne
correspond plus à saint piat ce cas un
néandertal parce que tout simplement il
n'a pas de chignons occipital donc là ce
qu'on voit là c'est l'arrière du crâne
et la forme du crâne et pluton
globulaires sans chignon occipital comme
vous pouvez le voir justement bien sûr
sur le crâne de pétra l'ona voilà le
chignon occipital c'est ça donc il n'ya
pas ça sur le rapide il m'a donc là
voilà ça c'est le fossile qu'il aurait
dû nous dont il aurait il nous parle et
ça c'est un fossile qui fout vraiment la
merde parce que si c'est réellement homo
sapiens et c'est dur à déterminer juste
avec un petit bout de crâne comme ça
mais six l'absence de ce chignon
occipital est vraiment significative
alors on a un homo sapiens plus vieux
que la plupart des homo sapiens moderne
africain voilà ça ça ça aurait été un
bon exemple ça manon banon il n'a pas
après comme je les dis c'est toujours
dit cherry picking c'est toujours
reprendre le fossile qui t'arrange à
l'endroit où ça t'arrange par rapport à
tous les autres fossiles qui t'arrange
pas il ya deux cent mille ans on a le
crâne de bodo on a le crâne de on
ad'autres crâne qui ont été certes aussi
et le crâne de floris bad qui ont deux
cent mille ans et qui ont une anatomie
un peu plus sa place
encore que celui floris badia pas
l'arrière du crâne mais sur hertault et
bodo on à l'arrière du crâne et il est
globulaires donc donc et ils sont
contemporains de happy dit maddon qu'il
faudrait ignorer ces crânes là mais bon
déjà là voilà ça ça fout un peu plus la
merde et saab été publiée dans nature
sait pas c'est pas l'arc entre opus un
truc obscures qui est sorti dans les
années 60 et qui a été invalidée presque
dans la foulée quoi
on continue c'est à dire que là je suis
en train de lui apprendre
je suis en train de lire à apprendre ses
arguments les arguments qu'il aurait dû
utiliser quoi c'est tellement mal
documenté que c'est moi qui sors c'est
propose les bons arguments qui devraient
sortir si ces constatations 800 le greco
vittek
ouais mais si ces 6es du prêt
néandertaliens bisang milan ça marche
très bien et vu que c'est du prêt
néandertaliens bas ça marche très bien
voilà je de cette montre que non non
parce qu'eux-mêmes
même en partant du principe là ce que tu
viennes de ce que tu vas me dire je vais
essayer de retrouver son chemin là ce
que tu viens de dire
texto 1 le garde ce que tu vas me dire
c'est gris copie tech a donné naissance
à l'arc en europe
à aucun moment tu dis que l'arc en trope
ces homo sapiens c'est l'ancêtre de vaud
sapiens donc là tu as juste de dire tu
vient d'affirmer sans aucune preuve que
gray copie tech et d'ancêtres d'arc en
europe et tu sous-entends que l'arc en
europe est l'ancêtre d'homo sapiens sans
jamais démontrer l'épreuve de l'un et de
l'autre
voilà donc non donc c'est non donc
encore une fois une référence ce type
négroïde de l'être humain avec son
canari qui apparemment a essayé de le
censurer en vain bipe dans le fond ni
deux j'ai déjà expliqué pourquoi ça ça
vaut rien de parler de couleur de peau
donc c'est là qu'on sent en fait que la
vidéo est faite pour ça c'est une vidéo
à propos de la couleur de peau
même si c'est jamais clairement enfin
c'est vraiment le seul endroit ici à 7
minutes 20 c'est vraiment le seul
endroit où c'est clairement évoquée mais
c'est une vidéo qui est sur la couleur
de peau c'est une vidéo qui essayent
absolument de faire naître l'être humain
blanc en europe voilà parce que l'être
humain blanc peut pas être originaire
d'afrique parce que l'afrique
des africains et et on les aime pas les
africains voilà qu'est ce que vous
voulez comment voulez que je comprenne
ça autrement comment vous voulez que je
comprenne ça autrement qu'à travers le
prisme du racisme d'ailleurs c'est vrai
cette idée de contorsionner la réalité
de ramasser juste les fossiles qu'il
faut pour prouver une théorie qu'on a
enfin c'est même pas pour prouver une
théorie c'est une opinion qu'on a déjà
il a une opinion celle que l'humain ne
peut pas être originaires d'afrique et
il prend que les fossiles qui
l'arrangent en ignorant tous les autres
et tout et il ignore complètement les
analyses génétiques une fois de plus à
autre une autre source
non non les analyses génétiques ont
clairement montré que l'homme de
néandertal à hachette ma merde
hachette ma merde mais mr ben ouais il y
en a beaucoup la hs mais merde non
l'homme de néandertal donc je disais
n'est pas n'est pas directement
apparenté à l'homo sapiens je peux vous
montrer encore une fois des analyses
génétiques qui ont été faites en long en
large et en travers
les analyses génétiques qui ont été
faites de néandertal elle montre que
néandertal et sapiens ils ont deux
souches différentes sur deux souches
différentes
et là vous avez les néandertal et les
denisot vient donc les néandertal sont
là les denisot bien ceux-là tout ça
c'est une analyse qui a été publiée dans
encore une fois dans knight ch donc
c'est pas des informations qui sont
dures à trouver et ses analyses
génétiques elle 10 néanderthals c'est
une branche différentes d'homo sapiens
est pas une c'est pal l'ancêtre d'homo
sapiens silencieux de néandertal était
l'ancêtre d'homo sapiens on devrait
trouver ce passage bleu l'a77 branche
bleus ici elle devrait se brancher à
l'intérieur des branches rouge ici de
néandertal donc ce truc bleus là il
devrait se trouver quelque part par là
et c'est pas le cas donc néandertal
c'est pas où il ya une partie évidemment
lui ce qu'il dit c'est qu'il ya eu
qu'une partie évidemment de tous et de
tous et sapiens donc là les français
voilà vous avez là
donc les français ici french devrait se
brancher ici et puis les autres il doit
se brancher à côté ça ferait un arbre
bleu donc ce que les analyses génétiques
elle suggère par contre c'est qu'il ya
eu effectivement un flot génétique
c'est-à-dire de l'hybridation
ce qui veut pas forcément dire que
néandertal et sapiens étaient de la même
espèce
ça veut dire que biologiquement il était
encore capable de s'hybrider donc ça
suit l'espèce biologique mais par contre
morphologiquement ils sont toujours
extrêmement distincts sapiens et
néandertal est génétiquement ils sont
aussi extrêmement distincts on n'est pas
en train de gommer totalement la limite
entre néandertal et sapiens ici on est
juste en train de dire que la limite
était peut-être un poil plus floue
qu'avant mais là la différence génétique
elle est telle qu'on a bien deux
branches distinctes
c'est juste que maintenant ces deux
branches elles ont quelques connexions
ponctuelle c'est tout morphologiquement
sapiens et néandertal c'est toujours
différent génétiquement néandertal et
sapiens est toujours différent il ya que
biologiquement on sait qu'ils sont
capables de s'hybrider mais ça veut dire
que sur les deux définitions de l'espèce
il y en a sur les trois définitions
d'espèce on a encore deux qui tiennent
sur les 3 donc ça va pour l'instant
néandertal il n'est pas prêt d'être
l'ancêtre de sapiens avant un moment
voilà c'est surtout ça qu'il faut c'est
surtout ça le message
mais voilà faux-pas faut pas confondre
quelques hybridation ponctuelles avec
ancestralité non néandertal c'est une
branche séparer de homo sapiens et
l'homo sapiens blanc ici représentée par
les français sont bien différents des
sont bien différents des néandertal
génétiquement et se branchent parmi les
autres d'homo sapiens y compris les
africains qu'on voit ici
les san donc tout va bien tout va bien
pour la pour la théorie dominante
la théorie des maniaques diabolique
dominante avec le démontrer car cette
origine mais on vient c'est intéressant
ça t'en vas dire la paix de ça avec leur
départ ont démontré par les touches pas
donc à bon bah là on est d'accord alors
néandertal est une souche à part car
cette origine on est en dernière se
retrouve
dans tous les adn de pratiquement tous
les peuples de la terre sauf dans l'adn
des populations africaines
subsahariennes
c'est à dire moi alors c'était vrai
jusqu'à un article récent c'était vrai
jusqu'à la publication de cet article
qui a démontré qu'en fait il y à bien de
l'adn de néandertal dans les populations
africaines
alors cet adn de néandertal c'est pas
néandertal qui lui a refilé directement
en fait c'est néandertal qui a refilé de
des gènes de néandertal au nom africain
et les non africains qui ont ensuite
redistribuer ces gènes en afrique
ce qui veut dire que tout ça ça s'est
joyeusement hybride est en gros après
que néandertal et disparus probablement
mais du coup ben ça veut dire que voilà
la néandertal on en retrouve des jeunes
non seulement chez les européens mais
aussi chez les africains et ça vous
pouvez le contorsionniste tous les sens
que vous voulez ça le contredit
totalement ce qu'il est en train de nous
dire et donc là c'est pas encore une
fois c'est pas des guignols 1 s'est fait
avec
c'est fait avec sérieux c'est publiée
dans la revue cell qui et c'est pareil
c'est pas là c'est pas une revue de
branquignols donc en gros on peut leur
faire confiance
mais là où c'est marrant c'est la date
de publication la date de publication de
cet article là c'est le 20 février 2020
alors que lui la date de publication de
sa vidéo c'est le 12 février 2020 donc
en fait il aurait pris le temps de faire
ses devoirs il aurait pris le temps de
faire des recherches ça lui aurait
peut-être pris une semaine et puis ben
il aurait vu passer ça ça qui contredit
absolument tout ce qu'il va dire tout ce
qu'il a dit déjà et tout ce qui va dire
à propos de néandertal qui n'auraient
pas refiler ses gènes aux africains ce
qui ferait la limite la limite tant
recherchée entre néandertal et africains
on est bien d'accord que du coup si
enfin je veux dire si on est bien
d'accord que si l'être humain européen
donc les blancs sont hybridés avec des
néandertal ça veut dire que les blancs
sont les seuls l'homo sapiens à ne pas
être pure entre guillemets 1 donc on est
bien d'accord que c'est à double
tranchant en même temps comme argument
l'argument de du croisement avec
néandertal alors certes ça trace une
limite entre artificielle entre africa
et européens
bien que comme je les dis cette limite
est finalement très très flou 1
encore une fois vu que les vu que
maintenant on sait qu'il ya du gènes
néandertaliens chez les africains mais
en plus c'est à double tranchant parce
que même s'ils avaient raison ça
voudrait dire que les africains seraient
plus pur que les européens
c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est chaud reçu
mais qu'il n'ya pas c'est un humain du
genre homo qui a paru il ya on l'a
retrouvé en eurasie
dans le nord il est très proche de l'art
comptera donc il est vraisemblablement
dans un sens c'est pas une connerie
puisque comme on l'a dit tout à leur arc
entre amp est un prix entraînée en date
est enfin l'arc en trope est en fait un
homo heidelbergensis sur envoi de
néandertal isation donc en soit ces
propos ce qu'il est en train de dire et
comme dans sa tête lui il faut
absolument connectés l'arc en trope à
l'homo sapiens même s'il n'a donné
absolument aucun argument en cette
faveur
mais comme dans sa tête il ya une
connexion entre arc entre amp et homo
sapiens même s'il ya pas de preuve
c'est plus ou moins logiques et 400
complet de ce qui n'est plus vraiment le
cas vu que cette comparaison c'est ce
conte de pourcentage la dn en fait il
était fait à ce compte de pourcentage
l'adn chez les populations dan et
néandertaliens chez les populations non
africaines il était fait justement en
comparaison des populations africaines
pour lesquelles on a su mais qu' il n'y
avait pas de gènes néandertaliens donc
maintenant qu'on sait qu'il ya des gènes
néandertaliens chez ces populations
africaines ça veut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de gènes néandertaliens
il ya beaucoup moins en pourcentage de
gênes est un pur mans néandertaliens
chez les européens
vu que en fait on s'est trompé à la base
en faisant le calcul en faisant calcul
on a pris comme hypothèse qu'il n'y
avait pas de gêne de néandertaliens chez
les africains donc en fait on quand on
faisait la soustraction du nombre de
gènes partagé par néant des
talent entre néandertal et les européens
par rapport aux africains du coup on se
trompait pas ce que les africains avait
quand même des gènes de néandertal dont
consul
on a surestimé en fait le nombre de
gènes néandertaliens chez les européens
je dois % d'année en complet il faut
savoir que néandertal et le porteur des
gènes des yeux de couleur claire bleu
vert et et aussi des cheveux de couleur
claire châtains longs au les asiatiques
quand tu as contre seulement 0 5% de
gênes de néandertal la rareté chez eux
des yeux et des jokers c'est aussi parce
que c'est pas aussi simple que ça encore
une fois les cheveux et les yeux c'est
quelque chose de très la couleur des
cheveux la couleur des yeux la couleur
de la peau c'est quelque chose de très
très compliqué génétiquement c'est pas
aussi simple que présent absent donc
c'est pas binaire donc c'est pas juste
du à néanderthal et maintenant on sait
d'ailleurs que néandertal bas toute
façon je vous ai montré l'analyse
génétique tout à l'heure si les gènes
qui ont conduit à la peau blanche sont
apparues entre 30000 ans et onze mille à
dix neuf mille ans et comme je voulais
dit à une autre analyse pas encore
publiés qui va probablement placer cette
barre à 8000 voire 5000 en bas
néandertal il est déjà plus là depuis
longtemps
donc ces gènes ces jeunes là ils sont
devenus ils sont devenus blancs entre
guillemets des jeunes ne viennent pas
blanc mais vous voyez ce que je veux
dire quoi les mutations qui ont conduit
à une peau et a des yeux plus clair il
ya des cheveux plus clair c'est s'aider
des mutations qui sont arrivés après la
disparition de néandertal
donc c'est pas ça ne nous a pas été
transmis par néandertal alors oui il ya
peut-être quelques gênes qui nous ont
été transmis par néandertal de peaux
claires mais c'est pas si simple et ça a
été confirmé par une étendre une étude
récente néandertal dinos given raid rbds
certaine ni changed the way we slip
puisqu'il ya des analyses qui ont été
faites récemment voilà l'article
original qui est ici c'est pour ça qu'il
faut toujours se documenter à la source
d information et pas seulement sur des
on dit voilà contribution to have
néandertal tout phénotypiques variation
in modern humans et donc c'est dans cet
article là qu'ils disent que haye
effectivement néandertal a participé à
la couleur de la peau donc contribute to
ce qui n'est guère kohler in trees and
day européenne a contribué à l'ap a
changé la couleur de la peau chez les
européens
mais à la fois sur des gènes qui donne
la peau plus claire et la peau plus
foncée
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure néandertal il y avait aussi des
néandertaliens à peau claire et
néandertaliens peau foncée la couleur de
peau
ça ne reflète qu'une adaptation à
l'ensoleillement rien d'autre et
certainement pas une filiation
voilà certainement pas la filiation
alors 7
c'est un caractère qui est génétique
dont qui se transmet donc il reflète en
partie la filiation mais c'est pas pour
autant qu'il faut ignorer tous les
autres caractères qui se transmettent
par filiation c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
est exprimé sous forme de enfin tout ce
qui est le résultat de l'expression des
gènes
voilà donc néandertal il y avait aussi
il y avait aussi des jambes bronzées
celle des basanés chez les
néandertaliens aussi suivant serait bon
ben maintenant il aurait attendu une
semaine il aurait su que c'était faux
alors néandertal n'est jamais allé en
afrique ça c'est vrai du mois maintenant
que le crâne de 2gb lire ou d identifier
comme homo sapiens on est à peu près sûr
qu'il ya pas eu de néandertal en afrique
avant ils étaient identifiés comme
néandertaliens donc bon il est
surprenant avions bien renseignés ces
gènes de néandertal ont été ré importés
par des populations d'homo sapiens donc
ça ça va je vois pas trop où il veut en
venir avec ça si enfin comme je disais
tracer la limite entre nay dire que
néandertal est jamais allé en afrique et
comme pour lui néandertal est l'ancêtre
de l'homo sapiens apparemment je sais
plus je sais pas à quel moment il a
chiffré entre néandertal est l'ancêtre
d'homo sapiens et néandertal est
l'ancêtre de juste des européens mais
bon bref
laisse tomber la cohérence
population moder de l'humanité moderne
c'est le type homo sapiens il fait
partie comme par contrainte
et comme néandertal du genre on s'est
créé pas comme ça il n'y a pas un tir et
homo sapiens est un [ __ ] c'est pareil
ça suffit de regarder sur wikipédia ils
écrivent pas homo sapiens comme ça de
celui qui dit lui aussi et les plus
anciens aussi les plus anciennes de
sapiens sapiens vous avez vu comme il
vient de dire que sapiens est apparue il
ya trois cent mille ans c'est à dire
exactement la date de djebel route du
crâne de djebel est rude mais vous avez
entendu comme il a juste complètement
occulté le fait que jebel heroes vient
d'afrique
vous avez entendu ça la magie de lignes
haut d'europe s'est passé sous le tapis
mais alors c'est à dire qu'il a gardé la
date parce qu'avant de gb lire ou de la
date d'origine d'homo sapiens était pas
300 mille ans ça peut ça sort pas de
nulle part cette date cette date
trois cent mille ans c'est la date qui a
été proposée en association avec l'étude
du crac de djebel i round qui a été
publié en 2013 ou 2014 je sais plus
exactement mais bref c'est de là qu'elle
vient à cette date de trois cent mille
ans elle était pas là avant elle n'était
pas là du tout avant cette date de trois
cent mille ans là ils viennent de nous
fermer alors une une contorsion de
réalité magnifique on l'a on réécoute
néandertal toujours lui aussi et les
plus anciens à leur arc en trope en plus
il a dit une énorme connerie arc entre
opus c'est un genre donc il fait pas
partie du genre homo par définition
enfin si on considère arc entre opus
comme valide ce qui n'est pas le cas
mais si on considère comme valide arc
entre opus fait pas partie du genre homo
par définition vu que c'est un genre à
part entière arc entre opus on a plus
anciennes traces de sapiens sapiens et
après on a à peu près 300 donc voilà
sapiens est apparu après néandertal il
ya trois cent mille ans mais pas en
afrique je joue bly ce passage là alors
là il fait une erreur qui est classique
c'est-à-dire datation égale filiation ce
qui est faux puisque dans ce cas là ça
voudrait dire que je suis le descendant
de
de louis xiv parce que je suis né après
louis xiv donc fatalement louis xiv et
mon ancêtre datation n'est pas égal
filiation hélas c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche
néandertal et descendants d'homo erectus
venue de revenus d'afrique qui ont migré
en europe sapent ya ces descendants
d'homo erectus des fois on appelle les
hommes les homo erectus africains d homo
ergaster et ses homologues aster ont
donné ensuite et d'albert gagnent six
africains qui est qui est différent de
l'edl bergen 6 néandertaliens mais bon
bref près néandertaliens c'est encore ça
c'est taxonomique mans c'est encore un
peu le merdier mais bref il ya eu les
deux bergen six africains qu'on appelle
aussi archaïque homo sapiens donc l'homo
sapiens archaïque et qui a donné homo
sapiens moderne les crânes de bodo et de
hertault sapiens pour résumer dans le
cas à un petit peu partout sur la terre
mais surtout pas en afrique natale
évolution linéaire quoi de l'évolution
on était à dix minutes je me disais que
j'avais plus trois minutes à souffrir tu
me sors cette merde non l'évolution
linéaire de l'humain et derrière il mais
ça bon alors l'évolution linéaire de
l'humain vous savez tous que l'évolution
n'est pas linéaire on nous apprend ça au
lycée au collège je sais plus bref c'est
buissonnant séduit ce nom il ya eu des
espèces dans tous les sens par entrant
pas vécue par entre opus a vécu en même
temps que que homo habilis et même que
les premiers homo erectus d'ailleurs
bref il ya des branches l'évolution
humaine n'est pas linéaire fin de la fan
pour ça je veux dire on le sait très
bien c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
truc que j'ai besoin de démontrer
maintenant l'évolution attention donc
nous dit-il l'évolution n'est qu'une
théorie non prouvée
va te faire [ __ ] déjà va te faire
[ __ ] va voir l'expérience de lenski où
on voit les bactéries évolué en direct
depuis 40 ans et va me dire après ça que
l'évolution des non prouvée je veux dire
regarde les bactéries résistantes aux
antibiotiques
vitesse à laquelle elles ont évolué je
veux dire résister aux antibiotiques
pour une bactérie c'est comme nous vivre
dans de la lave en fusion
donc c'est pas une petite évolution
résister aux antibiotiques pour une
bactérien c'est pas une petite
adaptation c'est une énorme c'est un
énorme saut évolutif un qui a eu lieu
chez les bactéries donc faut arrêter
d'appeler ça de la non évolution ça
juste parce que la bactérie elle
ressemble elle ressemblait une bactérie
elle ressemble encore une bactérie après
c'est pas pour ça qu'elle n'a pas évolué
son génome il a changé il s'est adapté
pour livre vivre dans un milieu qui
normalement devrait la flinguer
instantanément comme je disais c'est
comme si nous on apprenait à vivre dans
la lave en fusion
parce que notre peau soudainement
résiste à la lave mais parce que tu
ressembles encore un être humain
pour tout le reste bas en fait n'a pas
évolué non [ __ ] c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche
l'évolution allait prouver ta gueule
donc l'évolution est une terrine élimine
ont prouvé à laquelle je ne prétends pas
adhérer sauf quand ça m'arrange parce
que là je n'ai quand même de vous faire
une leçon de biologie évolutive ma
gueule ça fait dix minutes que j'en
parle j'ai faut surtout les points 1 1
mais ça fait quand même dix minutes que
j'en parle [ __ ] ses conclusions ne
sont valables que si l'on admet la
théorie évolutionniste
[Musique]
donc voilà il vendra son cul la
prochaine se dope preuve que la théorie
de l'évolution marche pas quoi là il
vient de vous faire un cours de biologie
évolutive pendant 10 minutes faut
d'ailleurs mais bon il vient de vous
expliquer que l'évolution démontré que
l'homme n'était pas que l'homme blanc
n'étaient pas originaires d'afrique à
c'est exactement ce qu'il vient de dire
pendant 10 minutes 1 l'homme blanc n'est
pas originaire d'afrique
d'après la théorie de l'évolution faire
la théorie de l'évolution montre que
l'homme blanc n'est pas des originaires
d'afrique mais attention moi si jamais
on me dit que la théorie de l'évolution
ça marche pas je suis prêt à changer la
vie tout de suite c'est girouette man
girouette man des cons dès qu'il y aura
un documentaire pseudo scientifiques qui
me dira que l'évolution n'existe pas ben
ben je dirais je dirai tout le contraire
et puis pareil avec la même dose de
preuve c'est à dire 0 1 parce qu'il
suffit de me dire que l'évolution marche
pas et puis après je chercherai les
faits pour démontrer que ça marche pas
on va pas d'abord on va pas d'abord
avoir des preuves pour changer d'avis
noms changent d'avis d'abord et on
cherche les preuves après 1 et qui se
sentent obligés de mettre un petit
cartel comme l'iran mais vous comprenez
je suis pas évolutionniste je suis pas
évolutionniste sauf si les blancs sont
pas originaires d'afrique
l'épreuve créée copie tech naissent en
grèce il y à 7,2 millions d'années puis
évoluent vers le genre homo avec la
recontre up de type européenne c'était
il ya 800 ans
puis l'heure contre évolué vers mais
envers table il y à peu près 500 clients
enfin apparaît au sapiens il y à peu
près 300 bilan et s'il faut donc voilà
ça tout ça tout ça c'est si on admet une
évolution linéaire de l'humain qui est
fausse basé sur des fossiles qui l'a
sélectionné lui-même parce qu'on les
trouvait en europe en ignorant
totalement tous les fossiles qu'on
trouve en afrique parce qu'ils sont
africains donc on s'en fout je veux dire
tout à l'heure il se plaignait de l'afro
centrisme mais là ils viennent nous
faire un anti afrocentrisme c'est à dire
que ce qu'il reproche ce qu'ils
reprochent la théorie dominante
en fait il vient de le faire mais en
contresens c'est tout je veux dire il
vient exactement de faire la même chose
que ce qu'ils reprochent aux théories
nord bref je veux dire tu ta pas plus
raison parce que tu vas pas ce que tu
vas à contresens c'est pas ça c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche
s'il faut aller là où il ya le plus de
preuves et là où il ya le plus de
preuves c'est en afrique c'est tout et
c'est bien après il ya à peu près 50 300
mille ans mais pas de jb wood known and
unknown et sapiens ont donné l homme
européen
et bien après il y à peu près 50 mille
ans que les cartables et sapiens en
donner
messi enfin encore une fois la cee'd
néandertal a donné naissance à l'homo
sapiens à quel moment ici bride
je comprends pas ou alors homo sapiens
il
il est né en europe en même temps que
néandertal était là ce qui est
complètement insensé je veux dire il y
avait déjà néandertal donc pourquoi homo
sapiens rennais en europe
il vient je dire tu peux pas dire que
néandertal a donné naissance à homo
sapiens et qu'ensuite homo sapiens série
brisée avec néandertal c'est débile
c'est débile
selon j'ai beaucoup moins toutefois avec
les autres pour donner l'espace athic à
grandir et c'est enfin l'afrique ar
bouder lui décembre est potentiellement
de greco pittet
sorti de mon chapeau ces grecs hôpital
qui a donné le l'homme africain parce
que parce que j'ai décidé voilà
l'épreuve
on s'en fout le même un vague
explication de où tu sors cette théorie
on s'en fout mais bon voilà
mais j'espère que ce sujet vous aura plu
c'était le nom d' encourager des gens
qui sont quand même les officiels dans
les mines string c'est assez rare pour
être signalé est assez rare pour
encourager ce genre d'initiative quand
les déchets comme ça les archéologues
vont à l'encontre d'officiels c'est bien
c'est pas un dogme c'est un paradigme
c'est différent un paradigme a des
preuves
ça commence par un p pour preuve un
dogme c'est ce que tu viens de faire un
dogme s'est tu tiens absolument à
prouver quelque chose
malgré le fait il ya pas de preuve ou
que les preuves sont insuffisantes
c'est ça un dogme un dogme c'est quand
tu cherche à prouver le truc métalleux
truc d'abord et après tu cherche à le
prouver
non la théorie afu la théorie de
l'origine africaine de l'humanité elle
est née un contre-courant
là pour le coup c'est dans ce sens là
que ça s'est passé les origines de
l'humanité elle était en europe parce
qu'on avait néandertal parce qu'on a ou
est elle était en asie éventuellement
parce qu'on avait erectus en asie à
l'époque on n'avait que l'homme de pékin
où l'homme de javols je sais plus je
crois qu'on avec l'homme de java et on
avait surtout l'homme de piltdown qui
est un énorme faut pour faire croire que
l'origine de l'humanité était en europe
l'homme de piltdown là l'une des grosses
motivations de l'homme de piltdown en
tout cas pas motivation pour créer le
faut mais pour croire que c'était pas un
faux c'était parce que il fut à
l'origine de l'humanité en europe donc
déjà des déjà au 19e siècle
on était à c'était au début du 20e
siècle
déjà au début du 20e siècle on était à
inventer des fossiles pour faire croire
que l'humanité était en europe et c'est
la découverte des australopithèques en
afrique qui a finalement fait changer
d'avis et la démonstration que gray cou
que l'homme de piltdown était un faux
qui a finalement fait shift est le
paradigme en afrique donc en fait là tu
t'inscris complètement dans un courant
mainstream mais qui était mal stream il
ya cent ans voit et qu'on a invalidé
depuis parce qu'ils étaient basés sur
des fossiles qui était pas assez vieux
néandertal et l'homo erectus c'est
relativement récent comparer
australopithèques us donc basé sur des
fossiles qui était pas assez vieux
et en plus basées sur des fossiles qui
n'était pas très abondants et dont
certains étaient faux et depuis on a
découvert pléthore d'australopithèques
en afrique et on a découvert des trucs
encore plus vieux est encore plus
primitif comme ça elle entre aux puces
comme horohorine comme comme
ardipithecus ardipithecus céder ce que
laissait un squelette entier
enfin je veux dire il ya de quoi
reconstituer un squelette entier on sait
ce qu'on sait sur l'origine africaine et
c'est pas été la théorie que tu appelles
mainstream
elle revient en réalité très très loin
elle n'était pas du tout même stream à
la base darwin
à l'époque c'était le premier crétins à
dira peut-être qu'en fait une origine
africaine et à l'époque on s'est foutu
de sa gueule clairement parce que darwin
il avait il avait aucune raison de dire
ça à l'époque à l'époque les fossiles il
était en europe et en asie il n'était
pas en afrique
à l'époque de darwin donc à l'époque où
la théorie de l'évolution a commencé à
naître les l'origine humaine elle était
en europe et ou en asie en eurasie quoi
et après c'est parce qu'on a c'est parce
que dans le mix on a ajouté des fonds
des fossiles qui n'étaient pas des vrais
et qu'en plus on a rajouté dans le mix
des fossiles beaucoup plus anciens
beaucoup plus primitives qui venaient
d'afrique on a finalement shift est le
paradigme pas le dogme le dogme c'est de
vouloir encore placé ça en europe alors
que tout va alors à son encontre
à part trois fossiles sélectionné mal
date est mal mal étudiés voilà un
probablement un bref on arrive à la fin
on arrive à la fin c'est presque fini
je pense qu on est encore loin jeu de la
vérité que la théorie proposée l'a
abattu je te le fais pas dire ça on est
loin de la vérité là c'est dommage parce
que la vérité on la connaît alors si
vous aimez ce genre de sujet
avec ce nom des tests adn
parlons-en de l'adn on a peu parlé une
seule fois de l'adn
c'est normal que tu en parles pas ça m'a
complètement à l'encontre de ce que tu
dis l'adn mais non j'ai pas aimé
voilà votre opinion et puis surtout non
donnez pas votre opinion vous n'êtes pas
des spécialistes
si vous n'êtes pas de spécialistes vous
n'avez pas à donner votre opinion
gardez votre opinion pour vous-même
elysées des bonnes raison des bonnes
sources scientifiques mes trucs achètent
mes t-shirts et machin il fait sa pub ça
suffit voilà c'était des bonnes kg
pénitence c'était douloureux ça a pris
des plombes pour une vidéo de seulement
13 minutes
pourquoi vous me fait faire des choses
comme ça voilà à très bientôt j'espère
peut-être pourquoi pas ciao